- I want the coffee so when that's ready,
please give it to me.
- Hold on to your knickers.
- I heard I can see your knickers,
And I was like, "What?"
- When he said it, it sounded
to me like he was singing.
(all laughing)
- I say the word knickers
the same way as you do.
- Guys, stop!
You guys are really leaning into that N.
- Don't put your knickers in a twist.
(all laughing)
(upbeat music)
- Hello and welcome to another
episode of Trash Taste.
I am your host for today, Little Baby Man.
- Stop doing this.
(all laughing)
- And together with me,
are the other little baby men.
(all laughing)
- The little baby men.
(Garnt laughing)
- Have you seen that image on Reddit?
It's just like the little baby men.
- [Joey] All three of us?
- [Garnt] I fucking love that image man.
(all laughing)
- Of course you do.
Finally, I'm as tall as you guys.
(all laughing)
- He's actually gonna be as tall as us.
- Yeah, exactly.
I saw some guy make it
his phone wallpaper.
And I was like, thanks guys.
- But yeah, you guys
probably haven't seen any,
like you guys probably
haven't felt any break.
We felt a massive break--
- Six weeks.
- Six weeks since we last recorded,
which to me has felt
like six months, right?
- Yeah.
- I'm like, it's one year
since I saw you guys.
(all laughing)
- I know.
- It's crazy.
- Oh my God.
But yeah like so if you didn't know,
me and Connor went back to the UK.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- For like three, four weeks,
and then we had two weeks of quarantine.
So basically scheduling that out,
it comes out to about six weeks
before we last recorded.
It has been like,
since we started Trash Taste,
I didn't realize how much my schedule
relied on me going to Trash Taste,
and just seeing the boys.
Because it was weird just not seeing
the both of you every week.
- I was so bored during September.
I'm not gonna lie,
while you guys were gone
like every Tuesday I
was getting ready to go
I was like,
"Oh, I don't have to."
- Honey I'm going to work.
- I'm going to work JK.
- Oh, we have our coffees, yes!
- Oh, finally!
- Oh God, I love this.
- Thank you.
- So yeah, we went back to the UK.
That was fun.
- Yeah, how was it?
- It was good.
- I mean, how long is it?
Like two years, or almost,
since you guys went out?
- Yeah, two years.
- Yeah, it's been about two years.
So it's been two years basically
since I've seen any of my mates there,
or my parents or my family.
- Same.
- Was it emotional?
Did you guys hug it out?
- Yeah.
- It was weird seeing my parents.
- Really?
- Because it was just like,
I've only seen them through Zoom,
for like two years,
and it was just kinda like-
- Right, right.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, it was weird having
conversations with people,
not through a discord
call or the Zoom call.
'cause you realize, I've
forgotten what it was like
to just actually catch up with someone,
not through a computer.
- Like, "Damn, look at those graphics."
(all laughing)
- I can touch them now.
- It's like no lag.
- I felt like, when I went back to Wales,
I felt like the Pope
going around a small town.
I was like, "HI guys--
- Really?
- "HI parents yes, come, give me a hug.
I'll give you, I'll take a
picture with your parents."
Okay, now I don't know.
It was nice.
I also learned from my past mistakes
of when I used to go back home.
I actually try to schedule
as many hangouts with friends as possible.
- Right.
- I reached out
to as many people as possible.
Because the last time I went home,
I just kind of thought,
"Yeah, I'll figure it
out when I get there."
And I ended up not doing anything
in like half days and I was like,
"Shit, I really should
have planned things."
- I did the same thing as you.
And then I think I made another mistake
and I think I planned two months.
- No, yeah, then that happened.
- Because then, I kind of realized
about like five, six days in,
not even like halfway through my trip,
seeing someone every day,
you haven't caught up with
someone for two years,
what do they wanna do?
Like crack open some
beers or bottle of wine?
And you just like,
you end up just eating
and drinking like shit
every single day.
- And so you basically downloaded
the alcoholic DLC.
(all laughing)
- Well, basically.
- Well, so I was there for 20 days
and only one day I didn't drink.
- Jesus.
- Every single day, I had at
least one beer or something,
just because that was like the thing
that you do in the UK.
- Yeah, I think 70 to 80% of my schedule
for my days there were seeing someone
or catching up with someone.
And that meant 70% to 80% of my trip
was like having some sort of drink.
- So that's how you socialize.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Do you drink with your parents?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, so your parents are
drinkers as well, all right?
- Yes.
- My parents don't drink,
- But you drunk anyway.
- No, no, but since we
haven't drunk in two years,
they brought open a bottle of wine
and they had a glass, I was
just like, "Oh shit, okay."
- This is special.
- This is a special occasion.
(Connor and Joey laughing)
I think I've seen my
mum drunk before this,
once in my life when I was
four at my cousin's wedding.
And you know, it was just
the weirdest fucking thing,
'cause my mom is like,
as far as my perception is,
like the biggest straight
edge there is, right?
- [Connor] Right, right.
- She doesn't drink,
she doesn't smoke,
doesn't do anything like that.
I had never ever seen her like...
In my life, I think I've seen
her take a sip of alcohol
about like, I think five times in my life,
total, total.
And then I remember going
to my cousin's wedding
and my entire family were there.
Everyone had like flown in from Thailand.
So it was a rare occurrence
that we have a massive
family gathered in one place.
And it was the first time
I'd seen a different side of my mom.
I had no idea.
I had no idea
that there was just this
monster laying within.
(all laughing)
And it felt almost like
she got more drunk than Sydney on the day.
Oh, she got drunk faster than Sydney.
And that gives you an indication
of how surprised I was.
And I remember like halfway
through the wedding,
I come sit down,
and my mom and dad are
just sitting on this table.
My mum has a glass of wine in front of us.
And I don't know how much she had drunk
at this point.
And she was like, "Gig."
Oh, my Thai name is Gig.
She was like, "Gig, do you wanna see me
down this glass of wine?"
I was like,
(Connor and Joey laughing)
"No, no, no mum, I don't wanna see you
down that glass of wine, mum, no."
She was like, "I'll do it, I'll do it"
I was like, "Mom! No, no, don't do it!"
And she just--
(all laughing)
And I was like, "Mom, what are you 15?
What are you 18?"
- Meanwhile, there's
like six bottles of wine
below her feet.
- And Sydney was on the dance floor.
This was like 10:00, 11:00 PM,
Sydney was on the dance floor.
Sydney was pretty not sober,
but she was like merry.
She wasn't completely drunk.
And then my mum just comes up to her,
takes the bottle of beer
that she's drinking,
just downs it in front of her
and takes it and gives it back to her.
I've never seen Sydney so
dumbfounded in my life.
(Connor and Garnt laughing)
- That's awesome.
- But yeah so, yeah, I ended
up drinking with my parents
a bit more which was a
very rare occurrence.
Of course, of course I'm gonna
share some alcohol with them,
but about like the fifth day
in and your body's just like,
"Please, please no more, like please."
I like the social aspect,
but my God, my body just died
like halfway through the trip I think.
- Jesus.
- Damn yeah, I don't know.
There's a thing where,
especially with my family,
they drink quite often.
So I feel like they saw it as an excuse
to drink more than usual.
So then it became a
thing where I was like,
"This is great, but I'm dying."
My dad's retired as well now.
So now, he loves it.
He's just like-
- Yeah.
- I thought my dad would
get bored being retired.
He seems like, I thought
he was one of those guys
that really needed like a
job to keep him occupied,
but yeah, and he fucking loves it.
He just gardens all day and he loves it.
It like he's like--
- That's the life, isn't it?
- Yeah, he's living his life.
- That is the life.
- He like bought a canoe
and I'm like--
- Oh shit!
- "Buying a canoe?"
Buys a canoe.
Where do you even store a canoe?
How do you even keep that?
I don't even know,
the logistics behind owning a canoe
seem way too difficult.
- Like, throw it in your backyard.
- Yeah, I mean, he seems
like he's loving it
and yeah, so it was nice.
- At least he's picked hobbies
that are gonna keep him active.
- Yeah, yeah.
- There's other things he
could have invested in.
- True.
He occasionally does do work,
he does like, helps a friend
with houses building stuff,
I don't know.
Yeah for me, that's all I saw.
- I mean, that's just like--
- He's chilling,
he's chilling.
- That's just retiring.
- That's what I've been doing.
- That's just peak retirement
- That's where I wanna be
when I retire, just vibing.
- Yeah, it was fun.
I went back and forth
between Wales and London,
it was a lot of fun.
I got to see as many friends as possible
and drank way too much alcohol.
- We did, we did.
I mean like 'cause we
posted a few pictures
while we're on break in the UK.
But I remember we were catching up
with a bunch of our friends,
and I actually hardly
ever talked to Connor
in our trip.
I mean, we obviously
like talked and caught up
and everything but we mostly
spend time just catching up
with other people.
- I don't feel the need
to talk to you guys.
- Yeah, we see each other every week.
- I fucking talk to you way too much.
- I feel that we had a
mutual understanding.
- I couldn't escape you.
- We've talked every week
for like the past fucking over a year now,
we can have a little bit time apart.
I think the only times
that we did do something together was,
I think we played like
a game of chess, IRL.
- Dude, I was drunk.
We were both drunk.
- We were both drunk,
and of course you beat me.
The only time when there was--
- Fortunately there was no cameras.
- No cameras.
No one watching it.
- The next chess tournament
should have a blood-alcohol
level measured before,
and you need to be X
amount required to play.
That's what we need.
- You just qualify if it's below 0.7.
- You're a little too sober for my liking,
you're not in, you're out.
- Got so many brain cells
for this tournament.
- Every time you lose a piece,
you got to do a shot or
something I don't know, just die.
This is what chess needs,
the next evolution.
- Drunk chess.
- We're going from casual chess
to absolute euphoric drinkable chess.
- I also like playing chess.
I remember playing chess against you
because we had a physical board,
none of this online chess business.
We went old school.
And we even had like a chess clock
and everything like that.
And I think I've realized
how much I've relied on the chess.com UI
to really like-
- Oh, it's very good.
- Be good at the game 'cause--
- Because otherwise you
have to look down like this.
- 'Cause I was pretty
intoxicated at that point.
But I remember I fell for
the most obvious checkmates
of all time.
- Oh yeah, I was great.
(Garnt laughing)
- I was trying to question
how I couldn't see that,
'cause we bet 20 pounds on the game.
I don't know why we bet
20 pounds on the game,
I think I was drunk at the time.
- Whenever I'm like
playing games with friends,
I'm like, 10 bucks, one buck.
Let's make it interesting.
Let's do it let's have fun.
- Fair, fair.
- Yeah how was your perception
of England going back?
- I wrote notes, I wrote notes.
- You wrote notes?
- Oh this is why you--
- Chris told me
to write notes and my phone is on 1%.
- You better read them all.
- So what I'm gonna do,
I'm gonna read through them all,
then we can talk about it.
- Okay.
- Very, very dirty.
(Joey laughing)
London is really loud,
I didn't realize how noisy it was before.
It feels like the same amount of people
are walking around Tokyo,
but in London it's less orderly.
- Yeah.
- Lots more homeless.
People making gestures or
saying something to you
whenever you do anything.
Like when I...
This guy just started
talking to me in the lift,
and I was really confused.
(Garnt laughs)
And I just forgot that
that was like a thing.
We started just talking and I was like,
I had literally just
checked into my hotel.
I just got off the flight.
I was like-
- what did he say to you?
- He was just like, he
was talking about like--
- Did you say hi?
- He was like, "How you doing?"
I'm like, "Me?"
- It's so funny to say that
'cause I literally got
recommended a video yesterday
of this satire news
report, that's just like,
"Northerner terrorizes Londoners
by saying hello."
(all laughing)
Literally what happened.
- Oh yeah.
People would...
Okay, when they bump into
you, right in Japan, right?
- Yeah.
- And I've totally forgotten
this was the thing.
This is the longest cable on earth, man.
When people bump into you
in Japan, they say sorry.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Someone bumped into me,
and those dickheads didn't say sorry.
- They didn't say anything.
- I could not, every
time that happened to me,
I could not stop saying
(speaks in foreign language)
(Connor and Joy laugh)
It was just like muscle memory.
Even if I hadn't bumped into someone,
I was like on the tune.
And I was like (speaking
in foreign language)
I was like, "I'm not in Japan anymore.
I need to stop doing
this 'cause no one else
is saying this shit."
I just couldn't stop saying
it or like subconsciously.
- I heard one thing that happens in Japan,
now I don't expect this,
so I just noticed that it was different.
When you get a taxI in Japan,
the taxI driver will always try
and help you with your bags,
even if you don't need it.
- Right, yeah.
- It could be the smallest bag on earth
and he might try and come out
and help you with it.
And that never happened with
taxis in the UK I noticed.
Every time I had a suitcase or anything,
they would just sit in the car
and then I'd have to open
the boot too as well,
which is fine, totally fine with that.
But I just felt, I was like,
Oh yeah, this is the
thing that we don't do.
And that was most of them.
Yeah, that was the most it.
- I'll tell you the biggest,
the immediate thing that I noticed
about going back to the UK,
that I immediately missed about Japan.
So, I think it was the second
day that we landed there
and also my second day in the UK,
and we went out to just
walk around Brighton again,
walk around town, because
it's been quite a while
since I've been in my hometown.
So, me and Sydney just went
out, did a quick shopping trip
and I got thirsty.
My throat was a little bit parched, right?
And so I started searching for a drink--
- I can see where we are going with this.
- In order to quench my thirst,
and I look around and I'm just like,
"Where are the vending machines?"
How am I supposed to procure some liquids
so that I may quench my thirst?"
And I walk around in this shopping center
and I'm like, wait.
And then I soon realized,
I have to go to a shop
in order to purchase some liquids.
- Not even a community
shop, like a supermarket.
- Yeah, like a corner shop.
And I'm just like, "What
backward system is this?
I need to go into a shop
that sells other things other than drinks,
and I need to do human interaction
in order to purchase this?
What is this?
- We really do take for granted
how many fucking vending machines
are on this country.
- I didn't realize that,
because sometimes, I'm
just walking around,
I get a little thirsty,
and I'm just like literally a minute away
from the next vending machine.
I didn't realize how convenient that was
until I went to the UK.
It's in a big shopping center,
most of this is just like cloves,
or different kinds of stores,
that are not like food drink items.
And even if it is,
most of them are something like super drug
or some very big pharmacy store
where they sell the drinks there,
but it's way bigger than it needs to be.
So I ended up like having to go in,
go into this massive store,
go to like the small segments,
just for food and drink.
- And then line up.
- Yeah.
- And I'm just like--
- Disgusting.
- Imagine lining up for things.
Not on my watch.
- Imagine lining up for a bottle of water.
Jesus!
(all laughing)
- But that's like the
first thing I noticed
where it was just like,
I really missed the vending machines
and just being able to
buy very conveniently,
buy like a snack or something .
- I felt that way as well,
whenever I got back to Australia,
or like the U.S or anything as well.
Because we have vending machines,
like in Australia and the U.S
but you don't have like a Suica.
- Yeah, like I said.
- So you have to reach in,
grab your fucking change,
jiggle that around and then--
- Yeah.
- I don't know why
they got you five fucking
vending machines in the West,
because sometimes the drink
doesn't even fucking pull back.
So I'm like, "Oh, good.
I'm about to gamble $3
to see if I can even get this.
- Sometimes you gotta double-pull as well.
That just happens sometimes.
- You're really lucky for that.
- Well, you buy a drink and you're like,
"I'm gonna buy another drink immediately."
But then, the machine is designed
in such a way that it just can't handle
two drinks being dispensed at once.
So you have to like fucking
scrunch your hand inside
and pull one out, just so you can unblock
this fucking thing.
- Yeah.
- But, I noticed as well, obviously,
I got at the airport and it's like,
"No one was wearing masks."
- Really?
- Yep, yep.
- No one was wearing masks.
I don't have fucking opinion on it.
I do whatever I'm told to do, I'm a sheep.
All right, what can I say?
- Wake up sheep!
- That's taking a stance in the self club.
- I really don't give
a shit, I'm just like,
If everyone around me is wearing a mask,
I'll wear a mask, you know what I mean?
But it was one of those things
where I was like,
"Oh, whoa, this is fucking weird."
'Cause in Japan, you'll be crucified
if you don't wear a mask.
- You could be in the
middle of a rice field
and they'll still somehow find a way
to crucify you.
- [Garnt] Exactly.
- And it was just like so strange,
just seeing everything
kind of back to normal.
It was like the UK just took the route of,
we don't give a shit anymore open back up.
But the rules are different as well
between England and Wales.
And because I was traveling between them,
on Wales trains, you have to wear a mask,
on English trains, you
don't have to wear a mask.
But some trains go from Wales to England.
So what happens is,
is that when you get into England,
people just took off
their masks on the train.
- Which does nothing.
- Which then eliminates
the whole point of...
Not that I think one of
either is wrong or right,
I'm just like,
It invalidates with both
that you have to put it on off.
You're on the same God damn train.
It was, whatever.
- That's like you being on a flight
and then like,
- Oh, well we're now in Russian airspace.
(group chattering)
- COVID is like, "Okay
guys, I'ma head back now."
- Sir, I can't survive
in this jurisdiction.
I need to get back.
(all laughing)
- So, it's like, "Okay,
that's kind of weird."
And I was wearing a mask
and I thought this was
early, like in America,
but someone came up to me and was like,
"Take off your mask."
- What?
- Yes, someone came up to me and was like,
"Take off your mask."
And I was like, "I don't think I will."
And then he was like, "Why?"
- Where were you?
- I was in Wales.
He was saying-
- Where you have
to wear a mask, right?
Still in Wales?
- No, no, no, you don't.
- Oh, you just did anyway?
- Obviously everybody was wearing a mask.
I looked like shit,
I wanted to cover my
face, I felt dreadful.
But he came to me and was like,
"Take off your mask."
And I was like, "No."
And then he was like, "Why?
Why are you wearing a mask?"
And I was like, I just ignored him
I carried on with my phone
and I was like-
- On the train?
- No, no.
Outside the train station.
And he was just like,
"Take off your mask."
And I was like, "No."
- Why?
- So I said no.
Some people get weirdly offended by it.
- It's like, "Sorry,
I'm protecting myself."
- At one time I was wearing it as well,
and the guy asked me, he was like,
"Are you wearing that for me or for you?"
And I was like, "For me."
- I think both, technically.
- 'Cause the thing was
that even though, you know,
'cause we had a flight to get on.
So I was coming up to that flight,
I was like, "I'm wearing a mask."
'Cause I do not wanna be having
to rearrange all my plans
and delay transportation."
- Yeah, of course.
- So that's why I was wearing it.
And then I was like, "Oh my God,
why are so many people coming up to me
and tell me to take off my mask?"
- 'Cause you're taking a stance.
I think going back to with him,
'cause I had very similar experiences
where every time I'd meet
some group of friends,
they'd question me of why
I chose to wear a mask.
Why I chose to put on this mask.
(all laughing)
(group chattering)
They didn't listen to me
until I put on the mask.
And so I get questioned about it.
And I'm just like, "I don't know.
I need to fly back to
Japan in like two weeks
and I'm pretty used to it.
And I just don't wanna take any risks."
I don't know.
That's just my opinion, man.
Like, I don't know.
- Why do you have to be accused
for protecting yourself?
- I'm not saying-
- That's like being like, "Why
are you wearing the condom?
Take it off."
- It's not like I'm
going around and be like,
"Put your mask on, put your mask on."
I don't give a shit.
You don't need it...
If the government tells you
you don't need to wear it,
I don't give a shit, don't wear it.
I'm just gonna wear it.
- But if the government also
says, "Don't wear a mask."
It's not like they're gonna
fucking take your mask away.
- I just feel like what I've
realized going back home
at least in England, it
became very political.
It's like as, you know,
as everything does,
but I feel like we got
sheltered from that in Japan,
because everyone here wears their masks.
And everyone here wore a mask before COVID
and that's why it was like super easy
to just integrate that into society.
Whereas like people just don't like
being told what to do in England
and America as well.
It was something where
just doing this one thing,
like wearing a mask,
in the environment you
are making a statement
or a stance or a choice
that was conscious, I guess.
I just never really thought
about it that deeply.
- I get that, but it's like,
I don't know why that is subject
to ridicule or criticism, right?
It's not like your doing something bad
by protecting yourself.
- Yeah, I don't know.
It was weird.
- I'd get it if it was
the other way around.
- Yeah, I mean, this was
the way I looked at it,
it was not even a political stance.
I was just like, I just wanna wear it
'cause I wanna wear it, fuck off.
- If I was wearing a hat,
would you tell me I can't wear a hat?
- Take it off.
What are you hiding?
- I'm bald head, bro, leave me alone.
(all laughing)
- Like me before going to England,
I'd never really thought
about it that deeply.
I think I've thought about
the difference between chicken
breasts and chicken thighs
more deeply than wearing a mask.
- You should have just turned
around to the guy and be like,
"It ain't that deep bro.
I'm just wearing a mask, get off my back."
- I was just like, "No."
I was like, "Leave me alone."
What the fuck are we gonna do?
- Rip the mask off of you.
- I was just like, Oh, my
God, I couldn't believe that,
I was just like, "Fuck off!"
- Jesus!
- One positive thing
that I think changed about England though,
since I've been back is,
ever since the pandemic,
a lot of big establishments now
have made it possible for you
to just order your food via QR codes.
- Oh yeah, that was-
- Yeah, yeah.
And I was just like,
Great!
We're getting to the
Japanese way of things now,
less human interaction.
Brilliant, I love it.
- Although, I was at Nando's.
I had to pause that
just for dramatic value.
I was at Nando's,
And I was trying to order my meal
and I was in a kind of a rush as well.
So I didn't have much time
and I thought it'll be easier on the app.
It turns out this specific
Nando's restaurant
just didn't have good cell phone service
and they didn't have free Wi-Fi.
So I was like fighting for my life,
trying to order this fucking thing.
And every single time
I got to one webpage,
it just could not get to the next one.
It was like, I had to keep resetting,
spent about 20 minutes
trying to order this meal,
but I only had 10 minutes to eat.
And then eventually went up to the counter
and I was like, "Give me this."
And they got my fucking order wrong.
(all laughing)
- He just couldn't get a dog.
- I was like, "Oh my God, man."
I'm fighting out here
just to get some Nando's.
And it was terrible.
I mean, it didn't taste good either.
- Really?
- The specific Nando's did not taste good.
And I was like,
- What did you order?
- I ordered a butterfly chicken burger.
- You mean the chicken breast burger?
- Yeah, chicken breast.
- Don't.
(Garnt laughing)
- Just don't.
Just don't.
- I had great Nando's when I was there.
I fucking miss that.
- The chips were kind of shit.
The coleslaw was not as
good as I remembered.
I dunno.
I don't know if my tastes are-
- Maybe Nando's
isn't just as good as you remember.
- Or maybe that Nando's specifically.
I need to try more Nando's.
'Cause I had KFC and that was fantastic.
I had UK KFC was so good.
- UK KFC is good.
- I miss that so much.
- I'll tell you the second
biggest thing I noticed,
which was, I really, really miss
Japanese food service.
It's-
- Yeah.
So many times I'd go to restaurants
and like half the tables
still had the shit
from the previous customers on it.
And I was like, "Oh yeah,
that isn't a thing in Japan,
that shit's gone immediately.
They won't even let you in the restaurant.
- I mean, sometimes
they'll take the plate away
while you're still at the table.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, 'cause I think, after being there
for like two weeks or something,
you you've had like all the food
that you missed from being in Japan.
And then after that
you go back to your usual eating routine
and you're just like, "Man."
You forget how good Japanese food is,
and Japanese restaurants in general,
because, you order anything here,
even if it's off E-breeze
or you go to random restaurant,
it is really good food standards.
And I'd just forgotten
how many British establishments,
were just really, really mediocre.
And after the novelty wears out of,
yes, I'm having all of these things
that I've missed being out of the UK,
after that wears off, you're like,
"Damn, Japanese food is just better."
It's just so, so much better.
And yeah, I've really felt that
in my last week in the UK
where I just missed having good food
on the daily.
I don't know.
- Did you have any Japanese food
while you were around?
- No, no, I didn't have any Japanese food.
- Some of my friends wanted to
and I looked at them like,
"No, we're not having Japanese food."
- It's like the first time I went to LA
and they took me to Little Tokyo,
I was like, "Fucking kidding me?"
I came from big Tokyo motherfucker.
- It's like that episode of Simpsons
when they go to Japan and
they go to America town,
and it's just like, "No, no, come on."
- Yeah, cause like what
I didn't understand,
'cause I just realized this is,
the UK is also an island
nation like Japan,
but Japan has really
spoiled me with good seafood
and fresh seafood
that you can find everywhere basically.
And just like getting
good seafood in the UK
is so fucking difficult.
And I don't know why it is,
'cause we're an island nation
that is smaller than Japan.
Our coastlines should be easier to get to.
Why is it so hard?
- Less distance to travel.
- Why is it so hard to find good seafood
that is not just fish and chips?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I did have a good lobster, actually.
- You did?
- Yeah, it was good.
- But how much did you pay for it?
- You don't wanna know.
- That's the thing, right?
It's probably like, if you
want good seafood in UK,
you probably have to pay
arduous amount of money for it.
- You do, you do.
- It was like a seafood pasta.
And I was really craving lobster.
'Cause I was like, we don't
really get lobster in Japan.
And I really wanted like a creamy-
- Do we get lobster in the UK?
- Yes.
- If you can pay for it.
- It's quite expensive.
Feel like most frozen canned stuff.
And it was really good.
It was probably the most I'd spent
on a single dish in the UK.
It was something ridiculous,
like $30, $40 or something.
But man, was the lobster was good.
It was so worth it.
- Worth?
- Yeah, everyone said while
having something like that,
like treating yourself to
something kind of that expensive,
it's very nice.
- Yeah , yeah, yeah.
- Definitely something
I felt so guilty for
when I was looking at the bill,
I'm like, "I literally had a pasta."
I'm like filing a mortgage.
I'm like, "Holy shit!"
- Yeah.
- I did something similar in Hawaii.
I had a $55 pasta.
- Once in a while,
you gotta treat yourself.
- But again, it was another seafood pasta.
I don't know what is best seafood pasta.
But it was like the entire
cost of a little mermaid
on this fucking pasta.
There was so much seafood on it.
And I was like,
"Okay, now I can see why $55."
I'll never do that again.
- I don't know how Australia is,
but I noticed that the
fancy restaurants in Japan
are cheaper than the fancy
restaurants in the UK.
- By far.
- By a lot.
- 'Cause in Japan, you
can go to a restaurant,
and you can buy a bottle of wine.
And even though it's
obviously more expensive
than it would be buying it wholesale,
it's still not that bad.
If we went out together,
we could split a bottle of wine
and it comes to like 20 bucks each, right?
- I noticed wine in
the UK was way cheaper,
which is why-
- Really?
Someplace I went to,
like the lowest price
bottles are like $150,
and I was like, "I want wine."
- What kinda bougie
ass place do you go to?
- Not even like that bougie places.
- But the wine was bougie?
- I think.
I don't know, I don't
know, maybe I should.
Fuck me for trying to eat good.
- 'Cause I remember going
to Tesco's and Co-op
to buy some wine and I
recognize some of the wine
that was available there.
There were like premium
wines here in Japan though,
that is like 20 bucks plus,
you can get a five or a
seven quid in like Tesco's.
- Yeah, but I think that's just because
Japan isn't really a wine drinker.
- That's exactly it.
And for the most part,
when I noticed wines that were available,
you can get wines for
like a much cheaper price
'cause if you're drinking wine in Japan,
you're eating good,
you're drinking good.
- This was the hard part,
I wanted to have the good,
the wine that was way cheaper and nice,
but I also wanted to drink all the beer.
So I had to like,
it was very hard
having to decide.
- You can't do both.
- You can't mix and match,
otherwise you'll end up in a,
you're gonna be in a coma the next day.
'Cause I had a drink the next day.
So I had to make sure that
I was in peak condition
at all times.
- That was the biggest
thing that I forgot about,
which was tactically
choosing how much you drink
so you can survive
and drink the next day as well. (laughing)
We sound like such alcoholics.
- I miss having like nice...
You can get IPA's and
stuff like that in Japan.
I love like the craft beer in the UK,
it's really nice.
- I miss having good ciders
Ciders was like the biggest thing there.
- Lagers.
- Lagers, yeah.
- I don't know.
I just missed that.
I drunk a lot.
I had Tesco meal deal as well.
- How was it?
Was it good?
- It was amazing.
I was like, "All of
this for three pounds?"
Get out of here.
- He says after having his lobster pasta,
he goes straight to Tesco.
- You know, I bought that lobster pasta
for like $30, $40, I don't
remember how much it was.
And it still didn't make me as happy
as that three pounds meal deal.
And it was better.
It honestly, a part of it tasted better.
I was like, 'Oh my God, I
get an innocent smoothie.
It's like a three pounds smoothie
in this three pound meal deal,
they're practically giving it away.
- I was happy going back to Nando's.
That was like the biggest,
I'm home now.
I am now home.
- I ate at Subway as well.
That was nice.
- Oh, Subway.
I've forgotten how good
Subway was outside of Japan.
Because Subway in Japan,
if you guys don't know,
you can't toast the sandwich,
you can't pick your bread.
- No.
There's like two choices
of bread, I think.
- What the fuck is the point
if you can't pick your bread
and choose to toast it?
I was so shocked
when you couldn't toast
your sandwich in Japan.
You what?
That's like the best part of any sandwich,
I don't even like Subway that much.
- That's literally the
drawing point of Subway.
- We can like Uber eat Subway here.
And sometimes when these
two don't wanna choose,
they order a Subway,
and I'm just like, no.
If I'm not having my subway
toasted, it is not a Subway.
- I had a lot of fast
food, a lot of fast food
and I'm surprised I'm not
obese by the time I came back
with the amount I drank and ate.
- Every time I saw you in the holiday,
I think you had a bag of crisps in hand.
- I went to town on Christmas.
- I think you were more crisp
than manner at a point.
- I was.
There was like one day
where we were hanging out
and there was just no food in this Airbnb,
but there was like family packs of crisps.
So I ate like 20 packs of crisps.
- I think your dinner
that day was like a hotdog
and like five packs of Doritos.
- It wasn't five, it was like eight.
- Eating like a true gamer.
- I literally went full gamer
mode and ate only chips,
crisps, I should say, before
British people kill me.
- I almost said chips as well,
which is why like I paused.
I was like, wait.
- I'm used to saying it for the Americans,
- The chips.
- The Americans watching.
But yeah, no, it was fun.
I had a great time.
I got to see all the
friends I wanted to see.
- That's good.
- A lot of things really worked out nicely
'cause I was asking people
like last minute to hang out
and luckily everyone was able to.
- I think I had enough rest
days, well, towards the end
because, my God, my body was just like,
I need to not touch alcohol
for like a month after this,
which is great, 'cause we've
had quarantined since then.
- Tell us about the hotel experience.
That's what I wanna know.
- Okay, no, no.
This experience doesn't
start from the hotel.
It starts from the point
where we get off the plane.
- It starts before that.
It starts before we've
left the fucking country.
It's already like--
- Well, me and Connor had two
very different experiences
leaving the country and
getting back in the country.
- So, I mean, how should we do this?
How should we split this up?
I have to go section
by section (indistinct)
So first of all, the most annoying part
which is to get even on the plane,
you need a negative COVID test form.
Okay, I am making a video
about my quarantine hotel,
things in-depth, stuff like that,
if you're interested by the way,
but I'll give you the...
I wanna talk more about it
'cause I didn't wanna bog down that video.
We are just complaining for nine hours.
So we are gonna complain
on Trash Taste right now.
So this whole thing is confusing, right?
So normally, if you want a negative test,
most test providers would give you a form,
say, "Hey, you're negative.
Take this."
And then everyone will
accept it, normally.
Problem is, Japan doesn't work like that.
Japan just decided, we've gotta do things
a little bit different.
- We doing it our way.
- It's literally our way or the highway.
- It's like, "how about
we just give you a form
that you need to fill
out the very specific way
that we want it filled out."
And this just sends fear
down, anyone who knows Japan,
'cause you know they're not playing games.
I have heard that some
airlines will let you on
with the negative test, and
you don't need that one,
but why would you risk it?
So, I was shitting
myself, 'cause I was like,
"How the fuck do I fill out this form?"
So this form needs to be
signed and stamped by a doctor.
It can't be a nurse,
it has to be a doctor.
The test can be administered by a nurse,
but it has to be signed
and stamped by a doctor.
So, the most testing
facilities don't have a doctor
who's gonna stamp or sign it for you.
So then now, you have to find a place
that has a doctor that will stamp it.
Turns out like none of these test centers
have doctors that are willing
to sign or stamp things for you.
So I managed to find,
I found after I basically...
I went to the UK government
website and got the email
of every single test
provider they recognize
and sent out a mass email to all of them.
This was a big mistake,
because then what ended up happening was,
it was one thread.
(Garnt laughing)
- They were all replying to each other.
- No, no, no, no, no.
It was a blank carbon copies,
they weren't replying each other.
But for me it was one thread.
So I sent this email off
and within about 10 minutes,
I realized the mistake that I'd made,
because I had 15 replies in one thread
and I couldn't keep track.
- So, you basically opened a forum post?
- I basically opened a forum
post directly to the person.
And so, I got like 50
responses in the first day
that all be like, "This is okay."
But then some of them were like,
"Yes, this is totally fine."
But they didn't say yes to everything.
So I had to then call
up places that said yes,
and I walked them through it.
And I was like, "Are
you sure this is okay?"
And one of them was like,
"Yeah, that's no problem.
We've done it all the time.
We've had people go to Japan all the time
from our facility."
And I'm like, "Great, okay."
So I booked on with them
150 pounds, it's like $200, right?
But, I know Japan.
I know that I should have
a backup, just in case,
'cause I don't fucking trust...
'Cause you have to get it 72 hours before.
So if I this up, I'm panicking
to try and find something.
So I booked two.
I booked another test,
but this place said,
"Book a test with us, and then
when you get your results,
three hours later, take those results
and book a doctor appointment
and then get the doctor
to sign and stamp it all."
So I did that too.
So I had that first.
So I went to this testing
facility at 8:00 AM,
they shoved a thing up my nose, I'm dying.
And then I get my results at
11:00 AM, and it's negative.
And I'm like, "Great, great."
So then I go to the doctor, and perfect!
They sign it all, they stamp it all.
It was all super easy.
But I had to pay individually
for both of those things.
It was like 150 pounds for the test again,
or, no, 90 for that one,
and then 90 for the doctor's appointment.
So this is already like 400,
500 bucks, just on the test.
- Not counting the amount
you have to pay for the test
to get in the country as well.
'Cause you have to pay for like...
A lot of things people don't
consider is, I spend a lot.
We both spent a lot on
just tests, basically.
- Oh, we did so many tests.
- Because you got to obviously get tested
before you fly out of Japan to the UK.
- That was like 150 bucks.
- Which was another 150 bucks.
And then you have to pay for another test
when you land in the UK as well,
which is also about 100 bucks.
- Lots of tests, so many god damn tests.
- If you're thinking traveling is just,
you just have to consider
the cost of the airline,
that's not a thing anymore.
- Which also they've increased
the prices on the flights
that they know people are flying.
So, like the direct flight
from Japan to London,
it was very expensive compared
to what it normally would be.
- Well, you also booked very late.
- I did book very late.
But even then, it was still
more expensive normally.
And so, yeah.
So I got this paper and I was like, great.
I have this Japanese document
signed the way I think.
I sent a message to Raina Sculley,
who'd also done traveling abroad.
And I was like, I sent her a
picture of the signed document.
I'm like, "Does this look okay?"
And she's like, "Yeah, it looks great."
And I'm like, "Okay, good."
But I had the next
appointment the next day
for the people who were like,
"Yeah, dude, it's all okay."
And I'll get it signed there and all that.
But to me it did make sense a little bit
because I was like, "How are
you gonna sign all this stuff
while I have to wait three
hours for the results?"
So I turn up to this test the next day,
'cause I'd already paid for it.
So I was like, "Fuck it,
I'll just get another test,
why not?"
I go there, and I'm like,
"Okay, so you need to fill out this form."
They're like, "No."
I'm like, "What do you mean?"
They're like, "No, we
don't fill out that form."
I'm like, "I called you up
and you said that you
could fill out this form."
And they're like, "No, no,
no, no, no, we don't do that.
We will give you a phone."
I'm like, "Yeah, but that's
not good enough for Japan.
I told you this on the phone call
and you said it was no problem."
And they were like, "No,
we're not doing that."
- Did you not read the forum?
(all laughing)
- Did you not read the thread?
And so then, a woman
came out of the office
and she was like, "Oh
no, no, no, no, no, no.
You're going to Japan?"
She's like, "Oh yeah, come
with me, come with me.
I got you, I got you."
And so I go there and I'm like,
"All right, so can you fill this out?"
She's like, "No, no,
I'm not gonna fill out.'
And I'm like,
"Why aren't you gonna fill out?"
She's like,
"Oh, because the form I'm gonna give you
is gonna be enough anyway.
It's gonna have your
passport information on it."
And I'm like, "All right."
But I already knowing that
I had the signed document,
put me at ease.
I probably would have
been very uncomfortable,
if I was in that situation
and didn't have a backup.
And I'm glad I didn't,
because I got my test results
after filling out this form and doing...
They were like, "We
promise, it'll be fine.
We promise this form will be enough."
And so I'm like, "Okay, fine.
All right, fine."
So I get my results back later,
it's got even less information on it
and no stamp, no doctor's signature.
Then like the other test result I got
to take to the doctor, which
wasn't even the real one.
So they've given me
this piece of shit form,
and then I went to the website,
I should have done this before,
and the reviews were
terrible for this clinic.
And then I found out it was a clinic,
but it was like a weird
modern medicine-esque clinic.
But it was a legitimate COVID testing...
They were allowed to do it.
- But not for official
documents, I'm guessing.
- Yeah, so then I was like, "All right,
"I'm gonna see."
'Cause now I have two forms.
When I go to the airport,
I'm like, "I'm gonna give
them the shit one first
and see if they accept it."
They probably thought I was
weird for doing this as well.
So I give them the form,
and then they looked really confused.
They looked really uncomfortable
and they brought like some staff over
and I knew they were
about to tell me like,
"You can't get on the flight with this."
And I was like...
And before they said anything to me,
I was like, 'By the way, I have
another form just in case."
And they looked at me like,
"What do you mean?"
"Like I have like another test
with the form filled out."
And they looked at me
like I was doing something really bizarre.
I imagined it would be.
They were like, "Why
didn't you just give us?"
Because I paid 150 bucks for this,
I wanted to make sure
that it was bullshit.
- This man limit-testing
the system right now.
(group chattering)
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- I wanted to see if I'd been ripped off.
And I realized now I played
paper please the other day,
and I feel like, oh, this is
what I did in paper place.
Some people just wouldn't give
that passport or something.
But yeah.
- Testing for bugs.
- They didn't tell me they
weren't gonna accept it,
but they were like bringing
managers over and stuff,
after I handed them this form.
And I was like,
"Let's not worry.
Let's not kick me out.
Here's the real one.
Here's the real one."
- Yeah, because I talked
to like a few people
who had traveled to their
home country and back to Japan
before I even flew,
and that's how I knew
about this quarantine hotel
that we were going to have to stay in.
And we'll get to that, but
every one of them told me,
"You need to get this form,
this form that the Japanese
government gIve you, signed.
Doesn't matter what any clinic says,
doesn't matter what they promise,
if you don't have this form,
you're not gonna guaranteed
to get back here."
And so you have to look
for a specific clinic
that can fill out this
exact form with a doctor,
which is a lot harder to find
than you originally think it is.
There's a big difference
between getting a positive COVID test,
which is all you need to get out of Japan,
but getting back into Japan,
you need to have this exact form
in order to get back in Japan.
And luckily, Connor went
a few days before me,
so I had like my own clinic booked.
And hearing about his second experience,
I'm just like, "Yeah, I'm just
gonna go for the proven way.
Yeah, let Connor be my beta tester."
- It was just like, it was so stressful.
I was just trying to get a
goddamn piece of paper signed
and it was like impossible,
but luckily, I managed to do it.
I don't know how it would be in the US,
I just know that getting
doctor appointments in the UK
is quite difficult unless
you're spending money,
like a lot of money.
So, and again, it's kind of
come under a lot of criticism,
rightfully so, 'cause traveling,
even though it's a luxury in general,
but they've made it ridiculously
expensive to travel.
I probably spent like 600, 500
bucks on COVID tests alone,
which I'm lucky enough to
be able to afford that,
but it's pretty fucked
that it's that much.
You know what I mean?
It's weird.
It's annoying.
So then yeah, got on the plane
and then it almost felt too easy,
'cause I got through check-in
and it was super easy.
Was it easy for you as well?
- Yeah.
It was very easy-
- Show them the paper,
they were like, "Yeah, have fun."
- Once you show the paper,
which was the same for me,
like going out of the country,
once you show the paper
and everything's accepted,
then it's the most stress-less experience
I've had in an airport,
because it's fucking empty,
'cause no one's traveling.
So you're like, no queue
for security or anything,
you just walked straight in,
and it's just a breeze.
Like after everything got accepted,
I've never had a more pleasant
experience in an airport.
And I never thought we'd
get a good experience
in an airport, until now.
- It was really chill.
I had a great time at the airport.
I was charging my devices.
In my terminal, I think I
counted, there was like 20 people
in the whole waiting area.
- Wow!
- For like the whole thing.
So you had your whole section to yourself.
- Yeah, but then it came to
coming back into the Japan,
and we always obviously
talked about the documents.
That was just the start of the process.
Because you get off the plane,
and obviously you have to
present the same documents
and everything like that.
And they put you in this
queue of just checkpoints.
- [Connor] It was like eight checkpoints,
that's before immigration.
So you do eight checkpoints
before you can even
get to what is normally the annoying part.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And you kind of like, you go in
and they present you these documents,
and then they give you a tag,
that you have to put over
your hand to identify you.
- It's like a fucking slaughterhouse.
- That is exactly it.
So you're literally like being
cattle, being herded through.
- It's how they know you're
going to the quarantine hotel.
They put this large thing
on your hand like this.
- [Garnt] They literally tag you.
- I took it off for a second
and someone shouted at me,
'cause I wanted to get my
coat off and I took it off
and they were like, two men came over,
shouting and panicking at me,
pointing at it to put it back on.
And I was like, "What the fuck man?
Give me a fucking second.
- So, they give you about
17 million documents,
that they will check
across like this journey
that you take.
And the thing is like,
you present this document,
they check it, great, go
to the next checkpoint.
Then also the same
document, and they check it,
you go to the next point.
And for some reason,
these few documents that you have,
get checked a total about like five times,
by different checkpoints,
even though nothing changed
between you walking
from point A to point B.
- There's like eight stops.
So the first stop is they...
So this is also a thing, right?
No one told me this.
You have to keep your boarding card.
Normally on airplanes,
I just like...
Fuck it, the moment I'm on the plane,
I just put the boarding card in my pocket,
scrupled up or something.
- Really?
- Because you don't it need
any more, you're on the plane.
- Yeah you do, the luggage tags.
What do you do with the luggage tags?
'cause that's normally on your card.
- Oh no.
They normally put that on
your passport or something.
- Oh really?
- Yeah.
But the luggage tags...
I know my bag, I've never had to use it.
- I always hold onto them
until I'm out at the airport.
- Oh, the luggage tags, I keep.
But normally the boarding card,
I would just scruple it
in my pocket or something.
- Oh really?
- No one told me you needed it,
because you never need it at an airport.
- I just hold onto it just in case.
- Just in case.
- I don't throw it away.
I'm not like on the plane,
fucking tearing it up,
but I don't think about it much.
I'm kind of just like whatever,
but yeah, you needed it.
So when you get off the plane,
they ask for like your passport,
your boarding pass and the documents.
Now, I printed off all the documents
that the Japanese
government told me to have.
Turns out that some of them,
they just give you on the plane anyway.
- Yeah.
- So I didn't need to print them out.
So I didn't even end up using my version.
I used the ones that
they printed out for me,
'cause it was like smaller,
and the one I printed out
was A4 and it was like a...
I don't really understand.
So, you have these two documents.
One of them is a declaration
saying that you're a good boy
and you won't leave your house
and you won't break quarantine rules.
And if you do, they'll deport you.
- Not ominous at all?
- And if you're a Japanese national,
I think they will do criminal
charges or something.
I don't know how much
they're enforcing it.
And another one was,
you have to circle the countries
you've been in the past 14 days,
and then just sign your name and stuff.
And then they always check this
and they put a lot of your
information on the sheet.
I didn't realize what sheet
was gonna be important.
- Yeah, I didn't either.
- So, yeah, the first check
is they check those documents
and the next one is the wellness check,
where they take your temperature
and then you have to do
a COVID test immediately at the airport.
- Okay.
- Like a PCR test, not
like antigen tests as well.
So the difference between a PCR test is
you have to take your spit,
whereas with an antigen test,
I think you can-
- Shove the thing
in your nose.
- They shove the thing in your nose.
And it's like an instant,
almost an instant response
for the antigen test.
With the PCR, takes like an hour or two.
- You need a centrifuge for it.
- [Director] It's the other way around.
The PCR test is the one up your nose,
I think the antigen test is the one.
- I think you can, I mean, I took both.
- [Director] PCR test is the
one that takes the most...
- All I know is that they
put it in a centrifuge.
That's the hard part.
I think that's why they can do it fast.
So you get asked, "Oh, you feeling okay?"
They check your temperature.
Again, I don't know what happens
if you have a high temperature.
I assume they just like put you down.
Like they just like shoot you
on the spot, I don't know.
- Grab the pillow and, silencer Pa! Pa!
- I imagine something like
Oompa-Loompas come out
and just take you away.
I don't know what happens.
- So, you get melted into the chair.
(all laughing)
- Because it's so fucking scary.
You are literally treated like cattle.
Anytime I asked anyone questions,
I got looked at like a fucking weirdo.
- Why is this cow taking?
- Before we go on to, and
I'll explain more of the flow.
I don't know, okay, I'll do it after.
So, you go to the wellness check
and then you have to do
a COVID test immediately.
Problem is, I was really dehydrated
and I needed to start spitting.
And I couldn't spit anything,
I was just spitting air.
And on the wall, they had
pictures of plums and lemons
to help you get some saliva.
(all laughing)
And I'm like, "This is not helping!"
- Why did they not just
give you a plum or a lemon?
- Because you're not meant to
eat or drink anything before you do it,
because that will dilute the result.
- Yeah, you do that.
Someone takes your test,
they will look at you
like you're the devil.
- But the thing is, you're in a room,
where you're just full of
a bunch of people spitting.
- It's really fucking weird.
- And they're spitting in this container,
it's not really like the nicest thing
to watch people spitting into this glass
or in this container.
And Sydney had like...
Sydney, after being on this
flight for like 12 hours,
felt a bit queasy.
I could just hear her in
the container next to me,
because she was feeling queasy
before she had to do it.
And her seeing people spitting
around, she was just like.
(all laughing)
And I felt so bad, it smelt so bad.
Because yeah, you do feel a bit
sick seeing a stranger spit.
- It's fucking weird,
it's really fucking weird.
- It sounds so post-apocalyptic.
- You do the spitting thing,
you give it to someone,
they check the documents that you have,
the right COVID barcode on your thing,
and then you go to a place
where they make you give your email
and then they send you an email
and then make sure you got it.
And that's okay, that's fine.
And then they make you install these apps.
I had pre-installed them.
But then I had a problem.
This app was so fucking junk,
when I selected my birth date as July,
it would randomly just go back to June.
- That happened to me too.
- Did it happen to you as well?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And I had to re-install
the whole app, and the internet was shit,
and it wasn't installing for some reason.
And they came over and they were like,
"Oh, here's a pocket Wi-Fi."
I'm like, "No, I've got 4G, it's fine."
I don't know this app is just dog shit.
I don't know what's going on.
It didn't install.
And it's this really fucking weird thing
that's watching you fill
out this app as well.
And I'm just like, "It's all right, man.
You can go and get help someone else.
I'm all right, I can do this.
Apparently the first time,
but I can fill it out."
And they make make sure that
your Google Maps thing is on.
And I was like, "Yeah, it's on already.
It's always on."
They were like, "Can we check?"
And I'm like, "All right, sure."
So I showed them and they're like,
"Okay, good, good, nice, nice, nice."
I'm like, "Oh yeah."
And then once I got that installed,
you go to the waiting area to
get your COVID test results.
- Which takes a couple of hours, right?
- No, no, no.
Mine took 30 minutes.
How long did yours take?
- Waiting, mine took about an hour.
- Okay, yeah.
Mine took about 30 minutes,
and then you get put into
the bus waiting area,
and that was a long time.
I waited like an hour-
- To be shipped off
to the butchers.
- It's weird, 'cause they've laid you out,
like you're sitting on a bus.
Did they do that for you as well?
- Yeah.
- There like in a corner,
and you're all sitting
like you are on a bus.
- It's like a dress rehearsal.
- It's like what they do on school trips.
- That's exactly it.
Where you have this teacher,
who leads you onto the buses
and you have to sit in the
exact same way you sat down
and I'm just like, "What is this?"
- And then, you know, once
you've got all that then...
Okay, so this whole process
is just part of like
three hours.
And then you can go through immigration,
which takes a while again.
But luckily, 'cause there's
no people traveling,
it's a little quicker.
But yeah, it does just takes time.
- Yeah, so, if you fly back into Japan
at the moment, regardless of how quickly
or how many people are flying in with you,
you're gonna be in the airport for around
three to four hours-
- I was there for five.
- Before you can get to immigration,
before you can even get your bags.
Because I was there wondering,
"Am I even gonna get my bags today?
What's happening with that?"
So basically, after your 12 hour journey,
which is what we had,
12, 13 hours on a plane,
you have to withdraw the four hours,
in an airport being herded,
through this system,
which kind of felt like
this dystopian society
where you were just treated like cattle,
like a piece of meat being herded through.
You are there to be processed.
- It's weird man, 'cause
I don't know what happens
if you just don't follow along.
It was just really weird and very strange.
You are treated almost like a disease
rather than a person,
which you know,
I don't give a shit about, it's whatever,
but it's just weird.
I mean, waiting for my bags took so long.
'Cause obviously when you
get your bags at the airport,
you can just go.
Because we're all on the same bus,
all dirty travelers.
We have to all wait till
everybody's gone through
and everybody's got their bag.
And then you can start going
through the bag checking.
Once you've got your bag,
you still got to wait.
And then, I don't know
if this happened to you,
did they bring out like
search dogs and stuff?
- Yeah.
- And they checked everything.
- My God!
- And I was like, oh my...
Bro, I don't think the dog
can smell COVID, can it?
What is this?
I'm like, "This is a joke."
And then they were like...
Did they interrogate you
about what you brought in?
- No.
- They were asking me like,
"Do you have any food?"
And I was like,
"I mean, I got some snacks."
And they're like, "What is it?
What is it?
What snacks?"
And I'm like, "Just like a nature bar."
And they're like, "Does it contain meat?"
I'm like, "No, it's a fucking
nature bar, I don't know."
It was just weird.
They were like grilling me
about these cereal bars I had.
And I was like, "It's
a fucking cereal bar!
What do you mean?
Look at it.
- It sounds like typical
Australian customs to me.
- When you illustrate
there, it makes sense.
- And yeah, we finally got through it,
and I was talking to
this old Japanese man,
'cause he'd lived in the
UK for like 20 years,
and he was just so funny.
He was just like, "I miss pub already.
I miss my friends.
I have good friends in pub."
I'm like, "Yeah, man, I love the pub too."
And I was like, "Wait,
where are you going to?
He's like, "Oh, I'm going to Kyushu."
I'm like, "You're going to Kyushu?
What the fuck?
'Cause you can't, how
can you get to Kyushu?"
So he was quarantining
in Tokyo for two weeks
and then Kyushu.
I was like fuck that
- Jesus, fuck.
- This poor guy was like 70.
'Cause this guy was a 70
year old Japanese man,
they didn't even try and
make him wear a mask.
He just took it off and no
one told him to put it on.
But anyone else who even took
it off, they stopped them,
and they were like,
"Put your mask back on."
- What are you fucking playing,
Squid Game all of a sudden?
(group chattering)
(all laughing)
I immediately befriended the old guy.
I would have won Squid Game.
We were just chatting the whole time,
but I was like, "Bro, I think
you should put your mask on."
I told him, "I think you
should put your mask on."
He's like, "They won't make me put it on."
He's like, "I'm too old,
they won't make me do it."
To be fair, they didn't make him do it.
I was really impressed.
He was that kind of amazing old man
that just did not give a fuck anymore.
He's like, "I'm far too old to
give fucks about your rules."
Which I respect.
Also, I was like, "Bro,
they've got guns, man.
Put the mask on.
It's literally Squid Game.
They have guns bro."
I was trying to help him out here.
- My God!
- And we got through.
Of course this old man,
they didn't make him open
his bag or do anything.
And I'm next up, they made
me fucking open my bag,
I've got like three bags and I'm like,
"Uh, for fuck's sake!"
He was like, "Do you smoke cigarettes?"
And I'm like, "No."
And he's like, "What about tobacco?"
And then he was like, "Do you have any?"
I'm like, "No. I just said, no"
- Can I have some?
- I just wanna hit man, I
just wanna hit, give me a hit.
- And then after that,
after you finally get through all that,
I'm assuming this is the same
for you, you get on the bus,
we get to wait 30 minutes
for it to fucking go.
And then, 'cause it was peak
traffic hours at this point,
it took an hour and a half
to get to the fucking hotel.
So not fun.
But where was your hotel?
- I can't remember where my hotel was,
but it was a different one.
- They blindfolded me in the bus.
- Honestly, I got in the bus
and I just like fucking conked out.
- Oh really?
- Yeah, yeah.
It was like Squid Game 'cause I was like.
- 'Cause it had the squid game music.
- They didn't need to gas me.
I fucking conked out myself.
Like, Jesus, fuck.
- Woke up on a bunk bed.
(all laughing)
- If they could have
gassed us, they would have.
- Congratulations, you're
here on quarantine day one.
- They took us-
- Only half of you will survive.
(all laughing)
- They took us all the
way from Haneda Airport,
which is like very south
of Tokyo to Ryogoku.
- Ryogoku?
- Ryogoku.
- That's like an hour and a half away.
- It was like North Tokyo.
- Yeah.
- And I've never been to Ryogoku before.
And it was literally,
we were staying right on
top of the Sumo stadium.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Okay, mine was like 20
minutes away from the airport.
- Motherfucker!
And so, yeah.
We'll get into how good
your treatment was, Garnt.
So, we get to this hotel
and I shit you not,
there is like 40 armed
guards at this hotel,
for like 20 of us.
It was ridiculous.
- It's like literally Squid Game.
- It was literally like 40 armed guards.
And all they did is you
watch you get off this bus.
And they're watching you the whole time.
But again, presumably I don't know why,
like this seems excessive.
- I don't even think the prison system
has that many fucking guards.
- These hotels have been
completely converted
into COVID hotels.
They're closed to the public.
There's one right in Shinjuku Sanchome,
I walked past it, and I saw all the guards
and with all their face masks on.
And it was just weird.
You have to wait, again.
You have to wait for fuck's sake,
you have to wait another 30 minutes.
Finally you get to a table
where a woman talks to you.
And she was explaining what
you could and couldn't do,
but her English was really bad,
and obviously again,
I know this is my fault,
I don't speak Japanese,
but I asked her a question
and then she just got really like, "What?"
She like didn't understand that.
And I was like, "Oh, maybe
I can ask someone else?"
And I felt really bad, but
then someone else came over
and who spoke perfect English.
And I was like,
"So come on, tell me what's going on?
What am I doing here, man?"
And also, this whole time,
during this whole thing,
I kept asking everyone at
every single checkpoint,
"Do you know how many days
I'm spending in this hotel?"
'Cause they said three days, right?
When does three days start?
When would you think it would start?
- Like the moment you
get to the hotel, right?
- That's day zero.
But, here's the thing.
- That's orientation.
- At every single checkpoint,
I asked people which day does it start?
And everyone said a different thing.
So, I didn't know how long
I'm staying in this hotel for
until I heard that thing where she says,
"Hey, you will get a test on this day,
and then if it's a
negative, you can leave."
That is when I found out how long
I'm staying in this hotel for.
And yeah, so, if you get a
negative test, you can leave.
But yeah, oh my God, it
was fucking terrible,
just getting there.
Not even to mention the hotel, oh my God.
- 'Cause what was your room like?
- So, it's a nice room.
And like APA hotels-
- You stayed
in the APA hotel, right?
- Yeah, did you not?
- I didn't stay in APA hotel.
- APA hotel is a chain of business hotels.
Also very famous for having
a very funny book in them.
Have you heard of this book?
It's a revisionist book
of Japanese history,
that is quite,
what's the word?
Racist, that's the word.
It was a really famous book
and it caused a lot of
controversy before the Olympics.
Like the Chinese team
refused to stay in the hotel
because of this book.
- Oh yeah , I heard about that.
- 'Cause this book, it
would say that like things
that Japan did never
happened and stuff like that.
It's kind of a somewhat
weird controversial,
and the owner is a controversial figure
of APA hotel, I think, as well.
Anyway, just a fun little history.
So this hotel, I had one of the rooms
and it's just a business hotel.
So you're not supposed
to be in there all day.
The idea is that you go,
you travel to like somewhere in Japan,
you do your businesses in the
day and then you sleep there.
- It's just used to shower and sleep
- It's got everything you need.
- I've stayed in the APA hotel as well.
Probably like they're
all very similar style.
I remember like there's
only enough space in there,
for a bed.
And there's no room to walk at all.
It is very much like a prison cell.
Because you do have a
TV, but the TV is like,
you can probably kick the TV,
with how close it is to the bed,
'cause it's like, it has like enough space
to contain a human being in it.
- And that's what it's designed for.
- Yeah, so I'm 5'10,
and my feet were just
at the end of the bed.
So if you were like
6'5, bro, you're fucked.
And I show it off in the
video a lot, that I filmed,
but you get this room,
and there's about two steps horizontally
and like two steps vertical
of walking the room.
So that's all the room you have.
You're not allowed to
leave the room, obviously.
And if you do try and leave the room,
there's an armed guard
outside who will shout at you
if you even opened your door
for longer than like five seconds.
'Cause I spoke to an
Irish guy who was there
and he said he wanted to get
some fresh air in his room
because you can't open the window.
You can't even crack it open.
The window doesn't open at all.
So if you want any fresh
air, like you can't.
So it's kind of, at
least by the second day,
my room started to smell not good.
And so I understand that he
wanted to leave his door open,
apparently like two guards came over
and like told him to close the door.
And if you do it again they'll like...
(group chattering)
- And then we never saw him again.
- And now, so you spend
three days in that, right?
If you get a negative
test, you get to leave.
The scary thing was,
is the moment I landed
and I got into my hotel, I got an email
from the Ministry of Health,
telling me that somebody on my flight
tested positive for COVID.
- Oh shit!
- So if I got COVID,
I would have to stay in
that hotel for 14 days.
So I don't know when
they change your sheets
or do anything like that.
- They don't change your sheets.
- But I was accumulating a lot of trash,
I mean, meals and stuff adds up,
and the bottles and stuff adds up.
- Wait, couldn't you get rid of that?
- No, only the meal, they
didn't collect bottles.
They took yours?
Oh my God!
- We'll get into that.
We'll get into that.
- Okay, the room itself is nice.
It's a good hotel except the pillow.
The pillow, oh my God.
This pillow is for sadists.
It's one of those
concaved-like medical pillows.
So your neck is like this,
'cause it's supposed to
stretch your neck out.
I do not wanna sleep on
that when I have jet lag
and I'm trying to just fight for my life
to get eight hours of sleep here.
And so I told Garnt, I was like,
"Bring your own pillow
because this pillows suck!"
But you didn't have APA hotel,
so I guess you didn't need it.
But yeah, definitely the worst thing was
not being able to walk or have fresh air.
And I thought, "Okay,
at least even in prison,
they get one hour of outside time of day.
Can I have one hour of
outside time please?
I want some walking."
But it's only three days, so it's not bad.
It was shit, but it had to be done.
- And then the meals were crap, right?
You guys sent me pictures of the meals.
- Yeah, yeah.
I posted one of them and I was like,
"This is the saddest breakfast ever."
And it caused a fucking
argument on Twitter.
- You must have got canceled
on Twitter for that,
didn't you?
- Everyone was like, people
like, man, Connor's privileges,
acting out so much...
- Didn't you say something
like, "I don't eat breakfast."
or something.
- I don't eat breakfast.
And this breakfast had like
French fries, slice tamps,
which is fine but...
There's single cheese
slices, sliced in half,
one small tomato, one piece of broccoli,
(indistinct) omelet, I still
didn't know what it was,
a really, really hard croissant bread roll
and cinnamon roll,
and three pieces of
macaronI for breakfast.
- I think in-flight meals
are better than that.
- Well, that's the thing
is that, people were like,
"This looks amazing."
I'm like, "Think about it.
This is breakfast.
I just want cornflakes or something.
I don't want this shit.
What is this?
I don't want cold french fries.
That's another thing, all
of this stuff was very cold.
- All the meals you get are cold.
- Cold and they are-
- You don't have a microwave.
- There's no way to heat it up.
It would've been nice to have a microwave
so I could heat them up.
'Cause some of them are nice.
There was one where they
made jerk chicken rice.
And that was good.
But most of them were really
ice cold, not that good.
But that one breakfast, oh my God,
that made me so depressed.
I was like, "This is it?"
- As if your situation
isn't already depressing.
- And everyone was like,
"You're so privileged Connor."
I'm like, "Look at it.
This is not a balanced
breakfast in any capacity.
No one should have cold
french fries for breakfast."
I was like, "What's wrong with you guys?"
'Cause they were like,
"In my country, that would be amazing."
I'm like, "What country?
Tell me your country."
(all laughing)
Whenever I've been to countries
that are not as wealthy
as other countries,
they normally have the best breakfasts.
'Cause they're always home
cooked and they're amazing
and they're like really
cheap, really filling.
I had Sri Lankan breakfast,
that shit was the best shit
I'd ever had for breakfast.
It was like a curry thing.
I would kill for that
over some shitty cornflakes or oatmeal.
Are you kidding me?
I got so annoyed about this whole thing.
And everyone who called me privileged.
- Well, it sounds like Garnt
had a much better time.
- So like I was prepared...
I was prepared for prison.
'Cause I talked to other
people who'd traveled before
and they had a very, very
similar experience to Connor,
where you did feel like you
were stuck in a prison cage,
and you couldn't leave your room.
I knew about the cold meals as well.
And like the one advice everyone gave me
before traveling was, pack snacks.
- Yeah, I brought a lot of snacks.
- 'Cause I'd seen the meals.
All I knew is that most
places had a kettle.
So I was like, "All right,
I know I'm gonna do."
I filled up an entire carry-on
case with just instant ramen.
I posted a picture on my Twitter.
- [Joey] I saw that.
- [Connor] Why did you need twenty?
(Garnt laughing)
- Okay, so before flying off,
I tell my mom, "Mom, I'm
probably gonna need snacks."
If anyone knows Asian moms,
they will over-pack food for shit.
And she's gonna be like,
"Okay, here's what you
need for the quarantine.
Maybe you might need a bit
more of you're missing home,
and you want a bit more ramen,
but you know what, I've got a few spare,
why don't I pack that as
well in the suitcase?"
And I just see a fucking
mountain of instant ramen there.
And I'm just like, "I can
survive nuclear winter now, man."
I'm fucking sorted.
Let alone for quarantine.
So I had like just a whole,
like a normal suitcase
and then just a carry-on
that was just full of food and snacks
prepared for this prison
experience I was gonna go through.
And so, I had exactly the
same experience with Connor,
going on the bus and everything.
Conked down on the bus and
woke up don't know where.
I was just like fucking Squid Game, like,
"Where am I?
Oh my God, okay, I'm ready.
I'm ready for the prison
experience to start."
So I get off, and first thing is that,
you get chauffeured in,
I didn't have any armed guards,
just like a bunch of people
who worked at the hotel
who are obviously like decked out.
- There was no security?
- There was security,
but they weren't armed.
They were just people.
It looked like they were just people
who worked in the hotel,
just with a full like
hazmat suit on, basically.
- Yeah, that's totally different.
- So, here's a hack,
here's a life hack that I learned
going through this process is,
if you're traveling with someone,
they will give you extra
privileges and extra rooms.
Because, Connor traveled by himself
and I was traveling with Sydney.
So, when they sat us down
and gave us the whole spiel of like
Oh, you can't do this,
you can't drink alcohol,
you can't leave your room,
can't open your window.
Yada, yada, yada.
And then I was just like,
Oh, I mean, me and Sydney are together,
can we get a bigger room please?
Because, my God, your room
contains a double bed.
- It was a semi-double.
- A semi-double.
- And that took up like the room.
- That took up the room, so I was like,
"There is no way I could
stay with another person
in that room."
So me and Sydney were deciding,
Should we just say we're separate
in case they do put us in the same room?
But I'm just like,
"Let's see what they say
if we say we're together."
And so I said, "Oh, I'm with Sydney.
Can we stay together, please?"
And they were like,
"Okay, we'll see what we can do."
And so they go off,
they talk to their supervisor
or something, they come back
and then they tell us,
"Oh yeah, I think we can get you a room
suited for two people."
At this point-
- The suite is open.
- At this point, I didn't
know what it meant.
So I'm like doubling down to be like,
is this room big enough for two people?
Because, if it is not big
enough for two people to stay in
for possibly two weeks, if
we test positive for COVID,
God forbid,
but if it is not big enough,
then we would rather have separate rooms.
And then they go off.
They were like chatting
again to the supervisor
and then they come back and they go,
"Yeah, I'm really sorry."
And I'm like, "Okay, maybe
we do need to get two rooms."
And they're like,
"Yeah, I'm really sorry,
all the king size beds are gone.
This one only has a queen size bed."
(all laughing)
- What?
Bro, you getting a five star experience
and I'm out here fighting for my life.
- Did your quarantine in the Hilton?
- I'm just like,
"I'm sorry, can you say that again?"
And they were like,
"Yeah, unfortunately all the
king size suites are gone,
so we're gonna have to
put you in the queen."
- I'm sorry, the room
has only three jacuzzis.
- "The queen size suite,
are you okay with that?"
And I'm like, "Yes."
I looked at a Sydney,
"Are you okay with that?"
And Sydney's like, "I think that's good.
I think that's good."
And so, we get taken to our room.
Did anyone like take you to your room?
- No.
- Okay.
- We had like a guard behind us.
- He'll like smack your ass.
- Yeah, he's like, "Don't
look behind or you die."
- So we had like four luggages with us,
like to two big luggages
and two carry-ons.
And so we've been lugging them around
the fucking airports and
it's like heavy as fuck.
And so after they check
us in to our rooms,
we go pick up, they give
us our meal right away.
There's a table with all our meals.
We pick one up and then I
started putting the meal
on the suitcase, and
started lugging around
and someone goes,
"Oh no, no, no, no, no, no, don't do that.
Don't do that."
- What the fuck.
I had like 10 bags, that
would have been nice.
- Yeah, I was like, "Oh, what's going on?"
And then they called another person over.
And then we have a luggage person
who puts mine and Sydney's
luggage on a trolley,
leads us to the lift, and they're like,
"What room were you checking into?
Oh, okay.
It's a Room 301.
Okay, that's on the third floor."
So they take us in, he
takes us into the lift,
presses the button for us
and then it takes us out and he says,
"Have a good stay."
And I'm like,
"Have a good stay?
What's going on here?"
So we get up to the third
floor expecting me and Sydney
to have to take over from there,
there's someone waiting
for us on the third floor.
And then they take our luggage
out and leads us to our room.
And before they check us in,
once again, they explain
everything we can and can't do.
And so this is like the moment of truth.
This is where I find
out how big our room is.
And I'm preparing for the
worst because I'm just like,
"Okay, I'm not gonna be able to walk.
I'm not gonna be able to do anything.
- It's Japan sizes.
We open the door and it's a fucking suite.
- Bear in mind, these hotels are free.
It's the government paying for them.
- Like this is a hotel I would
stay in if I was on holiday.
We walk in and there's a
hallway that leads to our bed.
So we walk in, me and
Sydney look at each other
and I'm just like,
"The Gacha gods are on my side!"
- What is this, a Trash Taste special?
Why is he getting a dab
and you're getting the L?
- The Gacha gods fucking
smiled down on me.
And we walk in and there's a hallway
before we get to our room.
And then we have like
a decently sized bed.
It's a queen sized bed.
And then we have an office segment
with a big desk and a massive TV,
that both me and Sydney can
use for desks to work in
if we really wanted to.
And we were just like,
'It's gonna be a great holiday, Sydney.
This will be a great fucking holiday."
- I've never thought
myself as a communist.
Sometimes I wonder if they have like--
- Are humans truly equal?
- So I remember...
- I was so pissed off when
he messaged me a picture
of his hotel room.
and I was like, I fucking hate you.
I hate you so much.
- Yeah, 'cause I remember
after I checked in
Connor was just like,
how's your room, man?
It's shit, isn't it?
It's shit, tell me it's
shit, tell me it's shit.
- I was like, please
tell me it's shit, Garnt.
Please tell me you hate
your life right now.
Just tell me I'm not alone.
Then he sent me a picture
and it was this fucking massive room.
- I didn't just tell him--
- This man could've ran laps in his room.
- I didn't just send him a picture,
I sent him like a video tour of our room.
The fact that I could send
like a video tour of our room.
(Garnt laughing)
- We live in a society.
We live in a society.
- And yeah, we,
I mean, we had a lot of
the same experiences,
but I mean, did you have a
laundry service in your hotel?
- What the fuck!
No, you didn't.
- No you fucking didn't.
What the fuck!
- So what we are allowed to do,
so we had a receptionist, right?
So when we walk into the room,
we notice that there's only
one pillow and we're like,
fuck, what do we do?
There's only one pillow,
we can't contact anyone.
So I'm just like, there there's this...
They gave us like a hotline
in case anyone developed
symptoms or anything like that,
that you can phone.
But then there's a small print that says,
you can phone this hotline
for any other requests
that you may need during
your stay as well.
And so we called them up
and they were just like,
oh, how is your condition?
And I was like, "Everything's fine.
There's only one pillow
in my room, unfortunately.
And there's two people staying here.
Could we get another pillow?"
And they were just like,
"Yeah, yeah, sure, don't worry about it.
We'll have someone
deliver a pillow to you."
like normal hotel service.
And then, so we get another pillow,
we start checking in,
we start looking under the instructions
we see that we can order
things to our room.
Like we can order Amazon
and we can order deliveries,
to our room as well.
- They said I could do that,
but they had like a
very weird list of stuff
you weren't allowed to order,
like burgers and pizza and chicken.
- Like food?
- Certain foods,
but it was really oddly written
that I didn't really understand it.
And you couldn't get certain
things like Amazon delivered.
They said that you couldn't.
- So we actually were able
to get Amazon deliveries
to our room.
We couldn't get Uber Eats,
we couldn't get hot food.
That was like the only
thing that we couldn't get,
which was hot foods.
So we can get Amazon deliveries,
we can get anything
that would help our stay
be more pleasant.
We had like a laundry service
where they would come
collect laundry at 7:00 AM.
And they would like
deliver it back to our room
in the evening.
- You can't make this shit up.
- We live in a society.
- It's so funny.
- We had like a garbage service,
they would pick up the
garbage every morning.
- I had my garbage in my room.
- We also had a masseuse, just like...
- Like they would give us
new garbage bags every day,
so we could fill it up.
And honestly, our food
aside from like being cold
was pretty damn fucking good.
We got like a pretty--
- Yeah, I saw your food,
it looked way better than mine.
- Yeah, we got like a fucking
decent bento everyday.
Some of this shit was better than Matsiya.
What was like the water
situation in your place?
- So you can ask for
more bottles of water.
A unit got one bottle of
water with every meal.
And I ran out 'cause I was a thirsty boy.
And I asked for more and they said,
"Oh, sure, we'll deliver it."
They never delivered it.
They just didn't turn up.
- So when we went in...
Oh, sorry, I forgot to say,
our place also had a minI fridge as well.
- Ah, mine did as well.
- Did yours as well?
- I think most hotels have minI fridges.
- It just like never got cold though.
It was just like--
- Just a container.
- They made it like less
than room temperature,
which I was like, I guess that's good.
But like, I mean, what am I gonna do,
call them and make them
replace the fridge?
- So we realized water would
be a very important resource
to fucking survive as it is.
They said you can use tap
water, but you know, obviously.
- It taste like shit in Japan.
- Yeah, it does.
So we go in and there
is two bottles of water,
which is standard, I guess,
for every hotel stay.
- I didn't even know that.
- You didn't?
- No.
- Okay, so they gave us..
They started off with two bottles of water
and then we opened the mini fridge
and it was a mini fridge
full of bottles of water.
- Oh, fuck off.
(Garnt laughing)
Mine wasn't even on.
I had to turn it on.
- So at the start of our journey,
we had like eight bottles of
water, which is brilliant.
And every time they delivered meals,
which was like three times a day,
which was like, they gave
us more food than I needed
because by the time...
I had the breakfast was massive
and by the time lunch
was being delivered--
- I often didn't eat breakfast
'cause I just wasn't hungry at breakfast.
- Yeah, by the time lunch was delivered,
I was still full from breakfast.
So I had a little bit of lunch.
And then like, by the time dinner came,
I was eating like a king.
I don't know.
- This man, this man, this man.
- It was a great experience.
- The dichotomy that we faced, oh my gosh.
- This guy is literally
living like a English king
during the black plague.
- Yeah, this man is a plague-
- While the peasants are
dying from the black plague
he's just like,
"Oh, there's too much
food here guys, fuck me"
- It's like, you know
that scene in Goodfellas
well the gangsters like go to jail,
but they're having-
- They're like champagne
- Like champagne and shit.
That's basically my
quarantine hotel experience.
I didn't wanna leave, honestly.
Me and Sydney woke up on the third day
and we're like, oh, do we have to go now?
Do we have to go back to our--
- Can one of us just get COVID?
(all laughing)
Just so we stay here
for like two weeks or so.
- It was just a free vacation.
I didn't have enough to pay for it,
didn't have enough to pay for the meals.
It was a good meal everyday,
had a hotel service.
- While this man living in the slums.
- Fucking great.
- Well, I got so depressed.
Like on the second, third
day I was miserable.
What's it called?
Cabin fever, is that what it is?
I couldn't even play games or watch shit,
'cause I was just so miserable.
- You were just like lying in bed?
- I was just like lying
there, checking Twitter
then just like, should I do something?
No, I'm too tired.
Why?
'Cause I can't fucking walk.
So I'm literally just
lying, sitting down all day.
- You're just bed-ridden.
- Yeah, and it make you feel fucking awful
I don't know, if it was terrible.
I know I'm gonna sound
just like a little bitch,
and I'm sure everyone's gonna say that.
- I saw the photos, some
of the photos you sent.
- I'd feel the same way.
- It's one of those things where
when you see it and hear it
you're like doesn't sound too bad
but then when you do it you're like,
"Oh, shit this is really depressing."
- Meanwhile me and Sydney
were just like playing games
on like the big screen
TV in the living room
and I'm just like it's fucking brilliant.
I'm like--
- Let's pull out the PS5 we packed in.
- I didn't have a game console.
I tried playing some games on my laptop
but I immediately was like,
oh, this shit is not comfortable.
It's not comfortable doing this.
And the smell of my
room was so goddamn bad,
'cause all the food.
It was like coagulating in the air
and my sweat.
- But then after reading a few more posts
and after like talking to various people
I think your hotel quality experience
is literally down to chance.
- Well, yeah, 'cause there's three buses.
I noticed there's three bus lines
and they all take you
to a different hotel.
And whichever one you go to,
you get a different experience.
- I think our hotel was
not just a business hotel
it was actually like a four-star hotel,
where they put us in.
- Certainly sounds like it.
- Yeah, which I'm just like,
Gacha luck man, the Gacha
lords are on your side.
- You know I will say,
this is kind of...
Don't make any more Squid
Game jokes but this is...
When I got on the bus that we all came on
there was like half the people on the bus,
which means that half of them got COVID.
(Joey laughing)
- [Garnt] Fucking hell.
- It was weird.
- First round elimination
- The Irish guy was there who I spoke to
and the old man was there.
So I was like...
(all laughing)
- What's up guys?
(group chattering)
- So I saw that guy without his mask on
in front of like seven armed
guards, not giving a fuck,
and I was like damn man, I did it.
- What day did you travel on?
- What date?
- What day?
- What do you mean like?
- Was it like a Saturday like a Friday?
- I don't know man, it was all the same,
it was all the same.
- 'Cause what I will say is that
I traveled on like a weekday
so like not many people were traveling
so I feel like...
I was traveling on a,
Friday maybe, I don't know.
- I mean, yeah, Friday's like a peak time
for people who are traveling
- I'm not sure you know,
I have to have a look.
- 'Cause if you travel on the weekend
I think more people travel on the weekend
'cause I feel like the
worst hotels are for like,
when there are too many people traveling
that it kind of like bleeds out.
Because, I think we didn't
have too many buses.
Which is why like, I think
we had like one or two buses,
and they all went to the same place.
So I feel like once that hotel
started getting filled out,
I mean if you think about it,
why would you need to drive
one and a half hours...
'Cause we flew in through
Haneda which is like south.
There's no reason to drive
to a hotel in the north.
- Well they drove to the hotel
and they drove us back to the airport.
And then when you get to the airport
you have to have a weird specific taxi.
You can't get a normal taxi,
can't book a normal taxi,
it has to be a quarantine approved taxi.
And the problem is that
I didn't know what time we were leaving.
So what time I should I tell this taxi?
I couldn't figure it out.
So I didn't know.
So I had to guess and I
had to wait for two hours
at the Haneda.
But the thing was, right,
so this whole period has
just been in quarantine.
They drop you off at Haneda,
and they're like, fuck off.
No one checks you.
No one makes sure and
everyone just went went off.
And I was like, where's everyone going?
Does everyone know where they're going?
I spoke to the Irish guy
who'd done it a few times
and he was like,
"Yeah, you can just chill
around the airport and wait."
I'm like, well I can just go to the cafe
and interact with people.
He's like, "Yeah, if you want to."
And I'm like, that doesn't seem right.
I didn't, I just I stood
in like a corner waiting
far away from everyone, and I
was like don't come near me,
I'm sick.
But I mean, yeah, it was fucking weird
and it was--
- You're literally like that dude
who's been in jail for most of their life
just trying to assimilate
back into society.
(group chattering)
- Yeah man, it was it was fucking weird
and not a very fun experience
and they've got rid of
it now, for UK travelers.
- Oh, really?
- Have they got rid of it, have they?
- They probably will soon.
- They reduced the quarantine time.
Before we flew,
I mean before we flew off to England,
it was six days in quarantine hotel
and then they got halved to
three days in quarantine.
- Six days in a hotel, fuck!
- Why couldn't be six days?
- He would've been all right.
- I shiver at the thought of
spending another day there.
It was nerve wracking, 'cause
the day I had to do my test,
they called me up and they said,
"Hey, when you get your
results if they're negative
you have to leave the room right away.
So you have to pack just in
case that you're leaving.
- But I didn't know
'cause someone on my
plane had been infected
there's a good chance
that I could have got it.
Luckily I didn't but
like they called me up,
they're like, "Your test
results are negative,
please leave the room
as soon as possible."
And like everyone's leaving.
And I was like, what the fuck,
I gotta get out of the room.
Which is weird, it was
really a shit experience,
don't recommend, IGN
is 10 out of 10 there.
- I wouldn't recommend that experience,
my experience wasn't that bad.
- Oh yeah, you got a free suite hotel.
- I remember Connor like
messaging me every day
Connor was like trying to drag
something negative out of me,
and I'm just like,
(group chattering)
And he's like tell me about,
Garnt, tell me about it.
I was like, honestly it's
just pretty good actually.
I'm having a good time.
He'd mention to me the
next day, me being like
maybe this this day will get to him,
this day will get to him.
- I'm sure something
bad happened since then.
- I went on Twitter as
well the day I checked in
and a fucking video from
Zed, the musical artist.
This motherfucker had like
a penthouse suite somewhere,
like literally a penthouse suite.
- [Zed] A bedroom and an insane view.
Look at this, just crazy.
I'm ready for the
quarantine, let's get it.
- And bear in mind,
Japan isn't even giving out
visas right now to anyone,
but somehow he got in?
- He got a penthouse suite in Japan.
- In Japan and he got a
visa to get in, somehow,
because he's doing a concert.
And somehow they made an exception
and people were not happy
because there was tons of people
in the comments being like,
Zed, you know that students
haven't been able to enter Japan
in two years, what the fuck,
and he's off here showing his suite.
And Zed didn't even have to
do a quarantine for two weeks,
only three days.
- Yeah so after the quarantine hotel
you still have to quarantine at home
for two weeks.
- For 11 days.
- For 11 days
- There were people trying
to cancel you for privilege.
- I was like--
- That's real privilege there.
- I made a joke 'cause he gave a room tour
that was like two minutes long,
of like all the different rooms he had
and all the shit he'd been sent.
He'd been sent like
everything you'd ever need.
Someone sent him like a
gaming pc for his quarantine
and I was like this is fucking stupid.
This is the stupidest shit I've ever seen.
And I made a parody video.
I was like, "Hey guys this is my room tour
and I just turned the camera
and it's just like the room
and that's the whole room.
And I was just joking.
I was just joking about how like,
the difference compared to rooms.
And then people got
angry at me being like,
you should be happy that you
even were able to enter Japan.
You know people haven't
been able to enter Japan
for two years, the privilege your showing.
I'm like what the fuck is this?
What the fuck?
I was so annoyed.
- You just can't get a dove there.
- So I deleted the tweet,
I was getting pissed off with the replies.
I was like what the
fuck are these reply...
And they're like why are you blaming me?
Don't blame me for being
a resident in a country
and getting back in,
blame the country for
banning any form of visas,
what the fuck!
- Yeah, exactly.
- They were like taking it out on me,
I was getting so annoyed.
I was fuming, fuming.
- I mean, those people
couldn't fucking tweet
to the Japanese government,
so they had to go for the next best thing.
- They were like,
"You're so lucky that
you can re-enter Japan."
Like, I'm lucky that i
can re-enter the country
I fucking live in, what
the fuck do you mean?
Shut the fuck up.
(Joey laughing)
Like what?
This is absurd.
Don't try and say that I'm lucky.
- That is pretty unfair.
- We're all unlucky
that the government has
some shitty rules on this.
Like don't don't take
it out on each other.
That's why I got annoyed about it
'cause people are attacking other people
who are able to get into the country
instead of, I don't
know, blaming the people
who are making the rules
and these arbitrary
rules between countries.
Like in America, some
states have to quarantine
but others don't.
And so there's this
whole weird thing where
it's like why, I mean it's
all one country, right?
- I mean, same with Australia as well,
like most of the states...
Like I mean, Australia had
that the fucking worst though.
Like, Victoria I think was in lock down
for 280 days in a row,
something like that.
Like, no interstate thing.
My sister was like,
yeah, I'm not allowed to
travel more than 10 kilometers
from my house, otherwise I get fined.
But like there's nothing stopping you
from just, if you live in like...
So one of the countries that
was banned was like Texas.
You could just fly--
- You mean state?
- Yeah, the state.
- The country of Texas. (laughs)
The state of Texas was like one country
that you'd have to quarantine
in, go to the hotel for.
But there were other states
that you didn't have
to go to the hotel for.
So like why wouldn't you just
drive over to the next state
and fly from there?
And just say that you've been there?
Because there's no way
they can validate that.
- They can check that, right?
- So to me it just felt
really like fucking weird.
But COVID has shown that
the rules are not to do
with what's practical,
it's political ties and all those things
if we've learned anything
and that's what is shitty,
is that it sometimes feels
like you're just caught up
in some international
bullshit politics of countries
that don't like each other
and countries that do like
each other and favoring.
I mean the UK did it a lot
too with countries as well.
They've been pretty bad for it.
It was just a mess and I
hated it and it's shit.
- Well at least you guys got to you know
sit here with me.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You guys made it, you made it.
- I mean like for the longest time we were
like literally trapped in this country
because we couldn't fly
out for the longest time.
And it was only recently
that the rules got changed
that people who are already
residents can fly out
and then fly back in, you know.
And I mean now we're just
waiting for the actual
people who are waiting on visas
because I can only imagine
that, that does suck.
Because we were really lucky
to be able to get our visas
before all this happened
otherwise we would have literally,
Trash Taste would have never happened,
if we would had applied for our visas
literally a few months
after we got our visas.
We would still be waiting now
to even get our visas to move to Japan.
It's actually crazy to think about.
- And Japan faced a lot of criticism
when the coronavirus started
'cause they banned...
Only Japanese nationals
were allowed back in.
Which is like okay I
guess that makes sense
but then they also didn't
allow green card holders,
permanent residents,
- Really?
- Yeah.
If you're like me you're British
and you're married to a Japanese woman
and then you went and
then you came back in,
if I was married to Japanese person,
they'd be allowed in but
I wouldn't be allowed in.
That came under a shit ton of criticism,
rightfully so,
because if someone's a permanent
resident of your country
that's literally like
where their whole life is.
You can't just say like, no, but they did,
and they faced a lot of criticism,
which they did eventually change
but they've still been banning visas.
And like I feel really fucking
sorry for these students
who've had their life on pause,
who had their whole
like basically two years
lined up in Japan,
they've just been banned
from entering Japan.
- They've just been waiting.
- It doesn't make sense to me
that they wouldn't allow some system
even if it's complicated
and even if it's fucking
stupid and tedious
to get in if you're a student.
Like I don't understand
why they haven't changed the rule on that.
It's just Japan being Japan, you know.
- Yeah it's because Japan thinks that,
oh, the foreigners,
you're more likely to get
it if you're a foreigner,
which is just not true.
- Yeah, it's just one
of those things where,
you can go through enough precautions
and you can do enough tests
to make sure that 99% of
the time you'll get it,
so that it's good and it works,
but I don't know to me it just,
I can't fathom it why they've banned
issuing any visas at all.
It really doesn't make sense to me.
- Yeah, I don't know, it's dumb as fuck.
- Yeah, and after going through that
quarantine experience like,
I don't believe anyone who's flying in
is spreading COVID. (laughing)
People, my God.
They have this shit on lockdown man.
- Yeah, honestly.
- I mean, yeah, there's like two tests
when you get here and your test before.
Obviously, somehow, someone
did get COVID on my flight
but that was caught
and then if you test
positive in the three days
you have to...
I understand it can still slip through
but also it feels like
such diminishing returns
at this point, to keep this rule in place.
You know, I mean it's whatever,
I'm sure everyone will have
a personal opinion about it
and that stuff.
I understand allowing tourists in,
obviously I get that
this is like, whatever.
- There like different
levels, there's tourists
which is opening the floodgates
but then there's people
who are literally waiting
on a working visa.
- It breaks my heart, man.
I really feel sorry for these people
who had their life lined up to come here
and they've just been just
hanging around, waiting.
Really, I do feel so sorry for them.
It's so fucked, it's really fucked.
- Well, hopefully soon.
I mean the the cases are
going down a lot now.
- I saw an article today that was like,
'Japan's drop in COVID
cases baffles experts.'
(all laughing)
But also I heard that
Japan isn't testing as much
so I mean yeah yeah...
- But I mean it's also because like
most young people now are
finally fucking vaccinating.
- Have we missed anything
since we've been gone?
- I mean the country's
opened back up again.
I mean in terms of like
the the 'lock down.'
So beginning of October they were like,
"Oh, yeah so everything's just good now.
Everything's open, you can
drink alcohol if you want."
Everyone's like, "Are you sure?"
'Cause you said that last time...
(group chattering)
We did that last time we
could only do it for a week
before you shut that shit down again.
(Garnt laughing)
- It was just like, the
floodgates were open,
everyone went out drinking
and then a week later
everyone's just like,
"Well, that was a good time."
- Experts were like,
"Yeah, that's a bad
idea, let's not do that."
- The Japanese government
managed to do something
that I think they've never done before,
test the patience of their population
and piss them off.
I've never seen people
get so actually angry
about shit in Japan.
It just doesn't happen,
but people actually
got so angry about them
keeping extending the lockdown
- Yeah, because they're so
fucking wishy-washy as well.
They're like, "Oh, yeah, so
the cases are going down,
it's not zero, but it's going down
so maybe we can open it up again."
And then it goes back up and they're like,
Experts are baffled.
- Surprised Pikachu face.
- Experts are baffled.
How did this happen?
It was going down.
- And the Olympics just like blew it up.
- Oh, my God, yeah.
- Oh, my God, just like I watched a video
about all the fuck ups of the
Olympics and it was insane.
Having it all in one video,
the sheer amount of people that got fired
off the Olympic committee is insane.
- It was like half of them.
- Yeah, and then the amount
of controversy, it was insane.
I was like this is fucking terrible.
- It was so fucking weird.
- Oh, my God.
- I mean so far it seems
to be going all right.
I mean the other day I was at a park
and with some of my friends
and someone was like,
we should do a bold gamer move.
We should drink a beer in
this park, and I was like...
It felt like someone
just offered me cocaine.
I was like no no,
I don't think that's a good idea.
I think someone's watching,
this this doesn't feel right.
I did it, it was very liberating but...
- Fuck the police.
- Yeah, I was like
fuck the police, they can't stop us now.
Yeah, I mean, I don't know.
I'm just waiting again for next week
for the government to be like,
"Changed our minds.
It's lock down again."
- Well, the real question
is, is karaoke open?
'cause that's
- Is that true?
- Everything is open.
- That's how you know
lock down's actually ended.
Once the karaoke opens,
that's like the equivalent of when
the British pubs were open.
- So the karaokes are open,
restaurants now go past eight o'clock
you can order alcohol,
basically, everything's back to normal.
- Well, some of the
restaurants are still closed.
- Some restaurants.
- Yeah it's kind of confusing.
- Which is basically,
it's basically most restaurants.
- 'Cause actually, the
day of filming this,
this is literally my first
day out of quarantine.
So I've not been out to explore the town.
I've just been stuck in
my or stuck in my house.
- You sound like Andy Dufresne,
like my first day of freedom.
- How was your 11 days at your home?
(Joey laughing)
- Honestly I prefer like the three days
in my quarantine hotel.
- I fucking love my home.
I was like, Oh my God, I
can walk, I have a space.
- I can walk.
- I can walk around,
I can shit in a bathroom that
has a bidet that's usable.
- Your hotel...
- It had a bidet, but it was like so weak.
It was like a duck tickling my butt hole.
I wanted something to power
wash my cheeks, you know.
- It was okay for like
a good five, six days
and then like the second
half of the quarantine
it really starts to get to you,
where you're just in your house
and you're seeing everyone out
and you're seeing the
country be normal, I guess
and you just kind of...
Luckily i have Sydney so
I had her to interact with
in case I was feeling too lonely.
If I was by myself--
- Oh, bro I loved it.
I had a great time.
- Really?
- Yeah, dude.
- The dichotomy of man.
- I was like I was testing like
every single Uber Eats out,
I was loving it.
My new place, I really love
and I got to like kind of work on it a bit
and I didn't schedule anything.
So I just had like the full 11 days
to just kind of do what I want.
I played some games--
- I mean you did that like
three, four days stream.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
I did a 72-hour stream
- Oh, yeah, you did do that.
- And guys I didn't say
anything racist in my stream.
- That was good.
- Well we don't know, I muted my mic
so maybe I did.
(all laughing)
- I saw a lot of mouth flaps,
couldn't make it out.
- Enhance, enhance, enhance.
- Expert lip readers.
- Lip readers.
- Yeah, I did a 70 hour stream not 72
because I had a Japanese
class so I had to end it.
But it did a 70-hour stream which was fun,
I had a really good time.
It was kind of last minute,
I was kind of like I'm
gonna do a 70-hour stream
and my mods were like,
"What?
You're gonna what?
No you can't do it, it's too soon."
I was like, "No, we're
doing it, we're doing it.
It's perfect time, I'm gonna do it."
- You were in quarantine.
- Yeah, I mean you're stuck
at home, you might as well.
- Yeah, it was good.
By the third day I was
getting quite tired.
I understand now why
Ludwig would watch clips
for so long, because after a while
I just was like, can I
stop talking for a bit?
Like can I just stop?
I'm getting really tired.
But it was fun it was fun.
Sleeping on stream was not as difficult
as I thought it would be.
I was generally just quite
tired from streaming all day.
I kind of just conked out.
- I tuned in right at the beginning
and then again right at the end
and it was like looking
at two different people.
I was like wait, is this the right link?
- I was starting to get
some really big eye bags
under my eyes.
- I could see that.
- 'Cause I think like I wasn't
sleeping like eight hours
'cause it's very hard to,
'cause when you wake up
you wanna check, make
sure everything's okay,
is everything working?
And people could have had the
ability to fuck with my lights
the whole time.
So people were making my house
a rave while I was sleeping.
What's that fucking meme edit
where it's like the outside of the house
and you can hear the music inside
and the lights...
- Oh, yeah.
- It was literally like that.
But I just played Trash
Taste episodes while I slept.
- Oh, wow.
- That was what I did.
- Easy content.
- Racking up those views, baby.
- I thought right, when I was sleeping
I assumed, 'cause when I was streaming
I had about 10 to 14k viewers concurrent.
Which was more than I normally have,
I was very impressed.
I thought when I was sleeping
it would go down to like 1000.
Turns out there was like
7,000 people watching this.
- Yeah, I was like, I saw that.
- I was like what the fuck.
What have you been doing?
- 'Cause I was like going through jet lag
and I'm like let's see
what Connor's up to.
He's like 7,000 people watching me sleep.
I was like fucking hell, man.
- I thought you did 7k normally.
(all laughing)
- My normal streams get like that
and i was like why am I...
I'm getting more sleeping, what the fuck?
- Are they like sleeping with you?
- I don't know.
- It's like I'm sleeping next to Connor.
- You know what was weird,
waking up and seeing like
people had subscribed
like paid to sub to me
while I was sleeping.
I'm like, shit, I should just
sleep on stream all the time.
I get paid to sleep, fuck me.
I'm kidding, it's weird though.
So I'm like why did
someone give me 50 subs
while I was sleeping.
It's like 300 quid, more
than that I think actually.
It's a lot of money,
I'm like, what the fuck?
- That's like the most generous
tooth fairy in the world.
(group chattering)
(all laughing)
I was like what the fuck.
What is this?
What's going on?
But it was weird and I'd
have like weird moments
where I would wake up but
i don't remember waking up
and I would see clips of me waking up
and I was like, I don't remember that.
- I saw a clip of you,
I don't know if you
were half asleep or not,
but you just like flipped off the camera,
like halfway through your sleep.
- I was trying to sleep, right,
and then people just
went ham with my lights,
and they just started
changing it every second
and then I was just like, fuck you guys.
Yeah, it was fun though.
I really enjoyed it.
I didn't think it was
something I ever thought
I'd be interested in,
but I thought, fuck it,
I'll try it and I
obviously had a lot of fun.
I'd recommend you guys try it out.
- No, I'm good.
- I'm good, man.
- I like my privacy.
- I can barely stream as it is.
- People always tell me, they're like,
"You guys should do a Trash Taste
where you just take it in turns streaming
and then like...
I was like, oh it could work sometimes.
- I mean, I feel like
if we did it as a group
it would be easier, but
like by myself, fuck.
- You do shifts.
Like we're together
sometimes but then shifts.
- I mean, I've done long
streams with other people,
that go for like 15 to 20 hours.
- I couldn't do it by myself.
- Yeah, I don't know.
I didn't have like many guests come on,
I just had (indistinct) play
with me which was great.
It's fun when you have
someone else to talk.
- Yeah, but that's the thing.
It's like if you have
someone else to bounce off of
then you don't have to be like,
likely talking to a chair.
- Here's one of the reasons
why I decided to do it.
So i had not been
streaming for like a month
before I left for the UK
and so I didn't stream for a month at all.
So I didn't stream for two months.
And so I have a second channel as well
and we like ran out of videos.
We had like no more videos left.
And so, Mudan, my editor was like,
"Hey, Connor, please,
please make like a shit ton of content
and I was like, all right I got you.
- 72 hours of story content.
- So the (indistinct) I
got like, I don't know.
like 10 plus videos out of it.
So I'm like there you go Mudan.
Here you go.
He was very happy now.
He's like, "Great, now I
have more content to edit.
This is great this..."
- More money for me.
(all laughing)
- Yeah, 'cause we have a deal
where we split the money 50-50.
- That's why he was desperate, he's like,
"I need to get paid, man"
- Well, yeah, because the
channel has been doing great
so he's like come on Connor,
we've got to keep up the content.
- He's like whipping you for content.
- He's now the guy who's
like, come on, man,
I need content, start doing
something, Connor, film it.
And he tells me, he's like,
"Play this game, it'll
be funny for a video."
I'm like, yeah, okay.
- He's your content producer now?
- Yeah yeah.
- It's a really good,
it's a really good balance
'cause we kind of started it together
'cause I didn't...
We were just like, okay,
I won't pay you for editing fees
but you get 50% of whatever it makes.
And then we thought we'd
be in the red for a while
or we thought he'd be
in the red for a while,
but luckily, yeah, it took off
and now it's doing really really well
and it's killing it
and some of the videos get like more views
than my videos.
- I saw that.
- One of them got like two million views
and I was like what the fuck?
Should have put this on my
main channel, goddammit.
But yeah, they're doing really well.
it's cool, it's weird, yeah, I don't know.
- I mean we also met
Mudan in the UK as well.
I got to catch up with him,
somehow he found two
days out of his schedule
to program himself out of editing and...
- He flew all the way from
Estonia to come hang out with us.
- My God, he is a machine.
I didn't realize this...
I didn't appreciate this until like
actually speaking to him in person.
- He's insane.
- Where he is insane.
I've never seen someone with
like a more strict work ethic
than he does.
- Oh, yeah,
the man never quits.
- I'm surprised he still has emotion.
'Cause you have to like
throw humanity away
to keep up with him.
- He edits videos in full time speed.
- Yeah, I know.
- He watches the video
in full time speed
- He told me that.
I was like, I don't think human
brain can comprehend that.
- I am convinced he's just
jacked into the matrix,
'cause how do you edit
in four times speed?
Like you don't do that
with a mouse and keyboard,
you do that in like Ghost of the show.
You like jack yourself in
and like he edits the video
in his mind, that's how I'm convinced--
- He's one with premiere pro.
- He does editing speed
runs on his Twitch channel
Like he edits like whole of
my videos in like four hours.
- Because I remember talking to him
when we were catching up
because he was with us
and like with a bunch of our mates
as we were like all catching up
and I was talking to him and I was like
oh so you're editing for like
Trash Taste, our specials
After Dark, Connor's channel,
Connor's second channel
and some of Joey's videos
and I've heard some of Aki's
videos in the past as well
and I'm just like, are
you close to burnout
and he was like,
"No, Garnt, I'm looking for more work.
Do you have more work for me?"
I was like, "What?"
- [Man] So like, he was
on his holiday, right?
He was like, "It's all
right, I can connect to my PC
through my phone, and I
can edit this for you."
At the airport and I'm
like, "What the fuck?"
- He's never disconnected.
- And he never quits.
- And he was like,
"Garnt, have you ever thought about
starting a stream channel?"
I'm like, "Mudan, how are
you looking for more work
right now?"
- He told that to me as well.
And he was like,
"I see you've been uploading
a lot on your second channel.
Do you want me to edit those?"
And I'm like, "No, I'm good, I'm good.
Enjoy your life please."
- I was just like flabbergasted
that this guy is still
looking for more work after
how many goddamn channels
he's already editing for.
- He's like a content black hole.
Like he just keeps
ingesting, it's never enough.
It's just like infinite.
- I'm just like, 'cause I asked him like,
"Mudan, what is your limit?
Have you ever limit tested yourself?"
And he's like, "No, I want
to know, give me more,
I'm nowhere near close to my limit now.
- He's got the limitless pill.
- And I'm just like,
"What the fuck, man."
What is this machine
that I'm talking to, man?
- He's like tested every
productivity app out there
to like find which one is
like the most productive.
So that he knows how he can
maximize his productivity.
He's insane, he's just
like a different breed.
- It's like a fucking T-100.
Skynet didn't send back a
foot fucking terminator,
they just sent back Mudan.
Like edit every video
on earth, on YouTube,
and he won't stop until
he like monopolizes
the entirety of any tube basically.
- I think if every person was like Mudan,
we'd be at like intergalactic
travel stages right now.
We'd be so advanced as a society.
- We have the dice and spear.
(all laughing)
We'd have had that by now.
- We'd be like a level two society,
just like controlling the solar system.
(all laughing)
Jesus Christ.
- I also feel like we'd be very dystopian.
I don't know though.
Yeah, it was fun.
The whole thing was fun,
it was really nice
getting to speak to him,
instead of asking him to do work,
ask him to have a beer.
(all laughing)
- Just hanging out and just
like having a beer with him
in person that was very nice.
This episode is sponsored by Manscaped.
- You know what's spookier
than seeing a black cat on Halloween,
it's shaving your balls
with anything other
than Manscaped tien.
- That is terrifying.
- When it comes to
below the waist grooming
there's no need to carve
your pumpkins this Halloween
because Manscaped is here to upgrade
your grooming experience.
Go for a bite-sized candy bar
to a king-sized candy bar,
and join the 2 million men worldwide
going to manscape.com
and using Trash Taste
for 20% off plus free shipping.
- Look at this, king shit right here.
- Keep the grooming game going
with the performance package 4.0.
Inside is the holy grail
of men's grooming items.
They've made it easy for you
to upgrade your grooming routine.
- Their finely tuned trimmers feature
a cutting-edge stramit blade
to reduce grooming accidents
thanks to their advanced
skin safe technology.
The lawnmower 4.0 is easily the greatest
ball hair trimmer on the planet.
And oh, did I mention this,
the trimmer is also waterproof too.
Gentlemen, I know this
trimmer is a shower essential.
- Quit trimming like a peasant
today and trim like a king.
Get 20% off free shipping
at manscaped.com/trashtaste.
That's 20% off plus free shipping at
manscaped.com/trashtaste.
- These nuts, back to the episode.
(Connor belching)
- I'm sorry.
- I'm just trying to think
of what i did while you guys were gone.
- What did you do while we were gone?
What did you get up to?
- Yeah, what did you do?
- Ah, fuck, what did do?
I saw my family here.
First time in two years
'cause like we all finally got vaccinated.
'Cause we all made a rule,
we were like we're not
gonna see each other
until we're all fully vaccinated.
'Cause my cousin, like my younger cousin's
only like three years old or something.
So I was like, God forbid I
didn't wanna give him COVID,
or any my family.
So we finally got vaccinated.
It's so weird because the
last time I saw my cousin
he's five now and he was
like two last time I saw him.
So it's just weird I was like,
I'm having a conversation with this kid.
- Oh, my God, yeah.
- It's so crazy fast
how like kids grow up.
It's just like, oh, it's a
completely different person now.
- We've reached that age now.
- It is, yeah.
And like I had a lot
of friends living here
from since I've known in
like high school and uni
who were like, "I haven't
seen you in a while.
Once the country opens
up we should catch up.
But it has to be a weekend
'cause I have to take
care of my two kids."
I'm just like, have we really
gotten to that stage now?
I've really gotten to that age 'cause like
it was just my birthday
like about a week ago.
And I was like, it's starting
to get to that point.
I mean you can relate Garnt,
'cause you're older than me.
but like I feel it's around...
- You're a boomer.
- Thanks for singling
me out though, go on.
- But like I feel I don't know,
at least to me, like around 27 is,
because I just turned 27,
it starts to get to the point
where it's not so much like,
oh, yeah it's my birthday.
It's more like, oh, it's my birthday.
- I've been like that for a while.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Age 8 to 15.
- Yeah, it's not like...
There's no like just that kind
of like childish excitement
of like getting older anymore.
It slowly starts to turn into that,
oh, God I'm getting older stage.
- Does that happen when you get 30,
is that when that happens?
- I don't know, like for me--
- As the only 30 year old here
(all laughing)
- As the only 30 year old here.
I remember like it didn't
didn't really hit me
until I was 29, I guess.
And so like every year like we...
When I lived in England we
had like this massive party
where we get to catch up with
all of our friends in England.
So we have this party every year.
And I remember it truly hit me,
'cause we were at this party,
and we're there for a few days
so I was having a shower in the morning
and then it kind of just hit me that
this is the last time I'm
gonna have this catch up
before I'm 30, in my 20s.
And then I just had this like
full-on fucking existential
crisis in the shower.
I mean, I take long showers,
I take long showers anyway
but like it was just me.
- That day that was a long shower.
- Even for me that was
a long fucking shower.
I think Sydney like thought
I got kidnapped or something.
(all laughing)
Like I was just standing there just like,
oh, my God.
Like I didn't know how to process that.
It was just like,
I think I took like an hour-long shower,
and then-
- Fucking hell!
- Well your hands must have been spongy.
- Oh, yeah, they were, they were.
The whole body was spongy.
And then like after that
shower I was completely fine.
- It washed away, down the drain.
- I washed my sins away,
I was ready for my 30s afterwards.
- I also knew that I was
like getting to that point,
'cause me and like a bunch of my friends
who were all vaccinated, so safe.
We rented out this like log cabin,
in like the mountains in Chiba.
And it was really nice 'cause you know,
I hadn't really had it like
a nightlife for about a month
since everything was like closed down.
It was like there's no point
going out to like restaurants
or anything like that at night.
So it was finally nice to actually get out
and change of environment stuff like that,
especially with your friends.
And I knew I was also
getting to that point
'cause all I received was
some pieces of clothing,
two bottles of wine and
a bottle of whiskey.
(all laughing)
And I'm like,
I'm getting to the point where,
I see a bottle of whiskey
and I'm like pog jamming.
I'm just like, "Yoh!"
- I guess 'cause after a certain age
you normally have everything
you want, you know what I mean?
Anything I'd want is like, yeah,
you wanna buy me a Porsche?
That's what I want.
- It's just like a gift that
a mate doesn't already have.
It's either like in an
acceptable price range
just doesn't really exist.
- It just gets bigger and bigger.
- It's either like you buy
them a new job or a new car
or a new house.
Well, what do you want, you know?
I can't really afford that.
(all laughing)
- Yeah, I mean, like I'd say another thing
that happened to me in the UK
that you've just reminded me of is,
I went to the Tesco's
to get my bottle of wine
then they asked me how old I was.
- I never get ID'd, ever.
- (laughing) And then I was
just like, "Oh, I'm 20."
- No way.
(all laughing)
- I had a moment like that too
and someone asked me how old I was,
like 23, oh, shit, 25.
- Yeah, I legitimately forgot at one point
how old I was turning.
I was like am I turning 27 or 28?
Fuck, I don't remember.
I had to like do math
in my head to figure out
how old I was.
- I'd literally like forgotten
that I had turned 30,
'cause like I had not been
asked for ID since I turned 30.
And so I...
By muscle memory I just
started saying 20 something
and I had like this Darren Brown moment
where I just forgot the
number and I was like--
- Vsource music plays.
- Oh no, I'm 32.
And they were like, "Can we see some ID?"
(all laughing)
And I was like, "Oh my God,
I get to show my ID again."
- I never get ID'd, I wish I got ID'd.
- Really?
- Yeah, 'cause--
- I never get ID'd here but...
- Yeah, I've never gotten ID'd in Japan,
for some reason I started
getting ID'd again
when I went back to the UK.
- I think I look older than
you sometimes, I think.
- What do you mean sometimes?
- Sometimes, sometimes.
- I think most days.
- I think most people
who tune in to Trash
Taste for the first time,
is like wait, Garnt's the oldest one?
- Everyone always thinks
that I'm older than I am,
which is fair enough.
Just means--
- And everyone thinks Garnt's like 23.
- Just 'cause I'm fucking
miserable, that's why.
I'm always complaining.
I can't wait till I'm 50,
I'm gonna complain about everything.
- It's the beard man, it's the beard.
- No, no, you have a good beard too.
- Yeah, but the thing is if
I shave this off, I look 17.
- Well, I look like a child...
There's plenty of Trash Taste episodes
where I don't have a beard.
And I look at it and I'm like whoa.
- Yeah, it's just like
you shave your beard
and instantly you just lose five years.
- Like 10, I think.
- Maybe you 10.
- I look like a 12 year
old when I have no beard.
- Whereas I feel if Garnt came
to a Trash Taste recording
with a beard like ours, he'd
look like a fucking like,
- I've had like a five
o'clock shadow before
and yeah I don't know how that looks.
I just don't like it
when my beard's too long.
- You just don't age, man.
(group chattering)
- I don't know, you could kill it.
- Yeah, you can kill it.
- Maybe I'll try it one day.
Maybe my mid 30s is the time.
(all laughing)
- You could have grown
one while you were away
and then come back, full
beard, "What's up, guys?"
- I have assimilated.
(Garnt laughing)
- Next time we have a break
when we don't record Trash Taste
I'll just let my beard grow
out and it'll just be like,
like the dichotomy of like
one Trash Taste episode
for the audience to be like-
- What happened during this week?
- Wow, Garnt really aged
during this week, didn't he?
(all laughing)
- Garnt just like does some
Doctor Strange bullshit,
or some nonsense or something
like that, oh my God.
I feel like a beard
could weirdly suit you.
- No.
I'm just not a big fan of
beards on me personally,
I don't know.
I also like...
There's this like patch
where a beard like can't grow
on my on my chin as well,
so I don't know how weird that
would look if I grow it out.
- I mean, I have a bit
of patchwork as well
around the place-
- Well, 'cause like the reason
I have this patch is because
when I was a kid I got...
Well it's not that big
of an exciting story
but my chin got cut open
because I was on the playground,
hit a kid, fell on the floor and then my-
- Split the chin
- Oh, shit.
- Split my chin open.
And so once that got closed
up there's just this patch
on my chin that just won't grow hair,
so I've always found it like-
- Just stick it, just stick something.
- Just stick something (laughs)
- Or just grow it out and
just like kind of bumble it.
- Yeah, braid it.
- Braid it into the middle
so it just comes down like.
- Why not, why not, why not,
you've gotta give it a try.
- Maybe, I'll probably will one day.
- I don't know if we
should get into anime.
I watched an anime.
(all laughing)
- I forgot we're an anime podcast.
What did you watch?
Squid game?
(all laughing)
- I watched Squid Game AKA Kaiji.
- I watched High Rise Invasion.
- What the fuck is that?
- Exactly,
what the fuck is that.
I watched High Rise Invasion on Netflix.
- Is that a new-
- Is that an actual anime?
- Look it up, google.
It's got a Japanese name.
- High Rise Invasion?
- [Man] There's a manga.
- What's the manga called in Japanese?
(man speaking in foreign language)
- When did this get released?
What the fuck?
- Wait, can I see?
What is it?
- I've never heard of this anime before.
- [Man] It started as a manga but-
(Joey speaking in foreign language)
- Yeah, so what happened is that,
I was like, I told myself,
I'm gonna watch the first
anime I see on Netflix.
- Why?
- What the fuck is this?
I've never seen this.
- And so I watched it,
and I was pleasantly surprised.
I quite enjoyed it.
- Really?
- It wasn't amazing, but it was good fun.
- It's a 6.6 on iMDb.
- And so when I started watching it,
it felt like the most 6.6 show.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- It was just good.
- I had a fun time.
- Just good.
- I had a fun time, it
was very interesting
and stupid at times and
dumb but interesting.
You guys should check it out.
Let me explain the plot to you actually.
- Please.
- Go on.
Whoa, Connor explaining the plot to us.
- Believe it or not
this is gonna be the most
scuffed plot explanation
of any anime-
- We are used to it.
- So this main character,
forgot her name already,
wakes up on the top of
a high-rise building
and you can't go down the
stairs of the high-rise.
You can only cross like wooden bridges
to get to other high-rise buildings.
And there's these dudes
that are wearing these masks
that are like budget
anonymous looking masks,
smiley masks and they're
trying to kill you.
And they're trying to...
They're not trying to kill you,
they're trying to get you
to jump off the building
by making you have such despair
but that goes out the window
within like 10 seconds
and they're just starting to kill you.
So it's one of those things
(Garnt laughing)
It's one of those things
where they build it up
to be like a really big plot point,
they're like they wanna
make you feel despair
and jump yourself and
then immediately like-
- Why don't they just come
up to you and they're like,
"Could you jump off please?"
- Pretty please?
- And then immediately they then,
these masks people just
start killing everyone
and then it was like, wait
so that wasn't important?
And then these masks are
like controlling people
and are trying to find
out what's going on,
and there's some other...
They're all (indistinct) so it's all...
All these characters-
- Oh, now I'm into it.
(Garnt laughing)
Why didn't you say so earlier, Connor?
- You can stop talking now.
- All these characters come
from a different world,
they wake up on high-rise buildings
and have to go from different high-rise
and there's like masks that control them
and it's kind of shit but
it was interesting enough.
I had a fun time.
You know what, it was nice watching a show
and not caring if it was
gonna be good or bad,
and I enjoyed it.
And the dub was very good, very good.
- Fair enough.
- The dichotomy,
because I think like this
was the longest stretch
where I went not watching an anime at all.
And actually picked up a JRPG
that I like got fucking
- Tales of Arise?
- Tales of Arise.
- Was it good?
- It was fucking amazing, man.
- Why did you have to say that?
Now I have to get it.
- The first time I played a JRPG
and like I'm just like-
- And actually completed it?
- No, I like, not only completed it,
I think I'm like close to 100% as well
- Oh, my God
- Like it's the only
fucking JRPG where I
cared about it so much
and I didn't want the journey to end
that I 100 percented the
fucking fishing mini game.
- That that's how you know.
- I caught every fish in this game
so I could see every skit
that there was available
in the game, okay.
- How many hours have
you put in this game?
- At the moment, about 80 hours.
So for JRPG length that's actually--
- That's not too bad.
- Especially for a 100%
run, that's pretty short.
- We're talking 80 hours in
like the past two weeks, right?
- Yeah.
- I mean, what else was he
going to do during quarantine?
- What else was I gonna
do during quarantine?
I mean like one thing that
really surprised me is that
it really got me to care
about game mechanics.
I'm just like, I'm here for
the story and characters.
And then I just got really absorbed.
- JRPG fans find out
that games can be good.
- And then I just got really
absorbed into the combat system
of this game.
And I'm just like, how did you trick my...
How did you trick my non-gamer brain
into caring about this shit?
Because like I've played
so many Tales games
and the reason I got it and Tales
was because it had like a
real-time combat system.
- Yeah, I played Berseria
and I didn't like it.
- Berseria?
- Berseria, yeah.
- Yeah, and that was in the time where
I only really got into Tales games because
every other JRPG was turn-based combat
with random encounters.
And Tales was just like no no no no,
how about you have a
real-time battle system
with enemies that you can see
when you get into a battle.
And then that kind of like,
as time gone on that
became more normalized
in a lot of JRPGs, like, you know,
you see the Modern Final Fantasy
and it's basically just an,
it's an action RPG with
some turn-based systems
implemented into it.
And so for the longest time
I still play Tales games
but they didn't grab me as much
as say back in the old school days
where this was the only
type of JRPG there was,
that had this type of system.
And so like, my love for the Tale series
had like waned a bit.
So when I got Tales of Arise,
I only got it 'cause
people were just like,
"Yeah, it's a new Tales game."
And I'm like, I'm a Tales fan,
maybe I'll just play this like--
- I'm more of a Sonic guy.
- Yeah, I'm a Tales fan,
I'm gonna ignore that for a second.
- I'm sorry, I'm sorry, that was terrible.
- I'm glad you said it before I did.
(Garnt laughing)
- He just kept saying Tales
and I just kept thinking-
- I was in my head I was
just imagining fucking...
- I'm a big Tales fan,
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
- Like if I wasn't in quarantine,
I wouldn't have played it
and then on the first day,
I played it for like a good 10 hours.
And I was like oh no, oh no,
I'm invested.
If there's one thing you
don't want to be invested in,
it's the JRPG because you just
have to basically write off
like two three weeks of your life,
if that happens.
- Pretty much.
- And it was like,
it's been such a long time where you know,
like when you're so absorbed into a game
that every waking moment
you're not playing the game,
you're either playing the game
or you're thinking about playing the game.
- I miss that feeling.
- And it was fucking great.
And the combat system in this is,
closer to something like, Devil May Cry
than it is like previous Tales games.
You can do like ridiculous
amounts of combos in this game.
Can I go off about the game mechanics?
Do you care about the
game mechanics at all?
- Sure, I mean, it's better
than you talking about
aero game.
(Garnt laughing)
I'd love to hear how you like it.
- Okay, so most Tales
games that I played before
it's just like button
mashing, like you press-
- That's what I didn't like about it
the last time I played it.
- Yeah, and you can get
through a lot of this game
through just button mashing
and then like, there's this
really weird difficulty curve
where the later parts of
the game, you were like,
before in every Tales games
you can just get away with
like tapping one button,
tapping special attack,
anything like that.
But then they've layered
so many different systems
onto this combat system from
like previous Tales games,
that you realize you can
just start layering shit
over like things over things,
over things, over things.
So they introduce you to like,
you can only do a certain amount of moves
before your character goes
back into a rest state.
So you can only do like
three basic attacks
and enough special attacks
before your meter runs dry
but then if you juggle the enemy,
you add more basic attacks on top of that.
And then on top of that, you
have group attacks as well,
where people in your party
can also join in on an attack
and then what I didn't realize is that
Tales added this system,
where you can switch to
another person mid battle.
So you don't have to pause the game
to switch to another character,
you can literally, it's
a tap of one button,
you can switch to another person.
So you can basically chain combos,
ends combo with one person
then switch to like,
do a special attack with another person,
switch to that person,
and so the system awards people
who are able to change really good combos.
'Cause if you get your
combo meter long enough,
then you can do basically
a finishing attack.
- It looked kind of like
Genshin a little bit.
- Yeah, that's that's the thing,
it's basically like, it
was a lot like Genshin
except not having just one person,
but having four people
in stage at one time.
- Yeah, in the sense that your chain
when you're playing Genshin
from how much more that you change.
- Yeah, but it's like way
more in depth than Genshin.
I would say it does have some similarities
to the Genshin combat system
but it's like way more in-depth
and you can get combos
that are like way longer
than Genshin.
You can get like 100 hit combos sometimes.
- The only thing that I found really funny
and I don't know if
this is the whole game,
but I was watching someone
stream it on Twitch
and they were fighting this
dragon, and during this fight,
every single character was
saying their voice lines,
at every single point.
And I was like, what the fuck is this?
I can't hear anything.
Everyone is just screaming
in their own attacks?
Is that happening all the time?
- Yeah, pretty much.
- That's pretty standard
for a Jap, you know.
- I couldn't hear anything,
I couldn't hear what anyone was saying
because everyone was
shouting their attacks,
I was like what is this?
- I mean, it's the same with
like, Xenoblade as well,
like when you're fighting.
- Oh, that shit I can't
watch 'cause that annoys me.
Xenoblade annoys me watching Xenoblade,
'cause I'm just hearing everyone,
(Connor imitating gaming sounds)
- And it's like four
people at the same time.
- Yeah, what the fuck?
- Don't you like that?
- No, 'cause I can't hear
what everyone's saying.
It's just noise.
- You don't have to hear
what they're saying.
- I can't, even if I
wanted to, I can't hear it.
- It's not like they're
giving important information.
- I just wish that it
was like, I don't know,
from a viewing experience it
was very annoying, at least.
From a gaming, it's
probably don't give a shit
to put to focus.
- I think if you're
watching it as a viewer
it might get a little bit annoying
'cause that's the only
thing you're focusing on.
But again, it's not
like they're gonna drop
huge narrative plot
points as they're going,
(Joey imitating gaming sounds)
I'm your dad.
(all laughing)
- I know, I know.
I was just like this is too loud, shut up.
- 'Cause on top of that as well,
sometimes the characters
will have conversations
with each other.
- That's what I saw as well.
As they're screaming.
- As they're screaming their attacks.
I mean there's a lot of things going on.
I love that, I love that about Tales.
- There's kind of campy about it.
- That's the anime side that I live for.
- Yeah, there's something super
campy about it that I love.
It's like, one person is being like,
"Hey, that was a good shot."
And the other one's like, "Ah!"
He's like, all right,
you're not listening, cool.
- It seemed pretty cool though.
It seemed like a lot better
combat system than before.
I don't trust people who
prefer turn-based combat
over that, I'm just like,
"What's wrong with you?
Who hurt you?"
- I mean...
(all laughing)
- I didn't say anything.
- Why?
Who is it, who is it?
Who in this studio
likes turn-based combat?
- I didn't say anything.
- I absolutely despise turn-based combat.
I fucking hate it.
- [Man] Turn-based is good.
- No, it's so boring.
- No, I'm with Connor on that one.
Except for Persona.
- We haven't figured a way to make it fun
so we keep using the same shitty thing
because we know it sort of works
but like no one's happy about it.
(Garnt laughing)
I don't like turn-based combat.
- I don't know, I'm
just used to it so much
to the point where I like think about it-
- But that's the thing though,
I think that's why people-
- I get it.
If you didn't grow up with
it, it's fucking annoying.
- Yeah, and I think it's just 'cause,
it's a thing that we haven't
figured out a better way
and I still feel that some games,
the whole real-time combat in a way,
is still kind of junk at times.
It sounds like it's good.
- It's really good.
- Sounds like they finally
figured it out a little bit.
- Yeah, it's really good because
they teach you the basics
and then they don't teach you all these
more advanced techniques that you can do
to basically extend your combos
and like make flashier moves,
but they give you gameplay
incentives, like I said,
like if you get a combo for long enough
without stopping it, then
you can do a finishing move
on an enemy.
And when they're high health,
it's harder than when they're low health.
So the common meter builds up faster
when they're low health.
So like when you sometimes
you start off a battle
and depending on how well
you can get your combo off,
because when when you kill one
enemy with a finishing move,
that makes it easier to do the next enemy
and the next enemy and the next enemy,
it's kind of like a domino effect, right?
So, depending on the difficulty,
if you start off a battle well,
you can clear the enemy so fast
or you can like get KO'd really easily,
depending on like how well
you start off your attacks
and your combos.
Which is just something that
I never experienced before
in a Tales game, because Tales was always,
I'm playing because I like it
and it's anime and it's JRPG.
And then the combat here is just to,
make me forget about the fact
that I just hate grinding
and combats and like
- Yeah, I don't like grinding.
- And turn-based battles,
but this one was just,
it's legit good game.
I can see why it's like the closest thing
Tales has got to like
a mainstream release,
because it is a legit
good game that I think
a lot of people who don't
even like JRPGs would like.
- I've been tempted ever
since they announced it.
And I'm just like I can't do it to myself.
I have so many fucking JRPGs lined up
that I still need to play.
I still haven't played
the like Nier Replicant.
- I haven't played that either.
- I bought that on Steam and
it's just been sitting there.
I'm just like, I'll get to it eventually.
- That's Steam, that's how it is.
- But I'll get to it eventually
and then they were like,
"Okay, there's five more JRPGs.
- I bought Sega Bass Fishing,
Sega Bass Fishing
and I never played it.
- Sega Bass Fishing?
- A fishing game.
- Oh!
- Sega Genesis type.
- Why?
- Why not, Garnt?
- Because it's Sega Bass Fishing.
- I actually think we should
do a Trash Taste special,
we do high score on Sega Bass Fishing.
Look at that game, look at that.
- Can we just go real fishing?
I'd rather go real fishing.
- I'd rather just go real fishing.
- And then play Sega Bass Fishing.
- I also really wanna play
the new Nickelodeon fighting game.
- They actually made it
into like a serious fighter.
- And apparently someone's
already figured out
that some characters are just
fucking broken beyond belief.
- Of course they have.
We're gonna begin patch notes
for days and tier lists.
Spongebob is STR, Patrick is DTS.
- Spongebob bottom tier.
- Bottom tier is (indistinct).
- Oh, my God.
Did you also hear the news just yesterday?
- I know you're gonna say it.
- What?
- Of Sora getting
confirmed for Smash Bros?
- Oh, yeah, I guess.
- And the internet just breaking.
I've never seen the
internet break that hard.
- I'm happy for those fans who like Sora.
I was rooting for Master
Chief, personally.
- Aki literally broke down crying
as if she lost a family member.
- Does Aki play Smash?
- She does, but I didn't
know she played...
'Cause she never played with me.
But apparently she's
played like the 3DS variant
and stuff like that.
Like the older game.
But now, I know there's
gonna be just like a whole
wave of new smash players.
- It's one of those things
where I'm happy for those fans
who got it, but I don't really care.
I could care less-
- I mean, I never played Kingdom Hearts.
- No, me neither.
- Me neither.
(Garnt laughing)
- Were you hyped?
- I mean I was hyped just
purely on the base of like
just thinking to myself how the fuck,
like they must have thought
for tooth and nail with Disney
to get that.
- Maybe.
Maybe smash is big enough where
they would have been like...
- Oh, yeah, I'm sure.
Like Sakurai's done enough now,
where he's just like,
"Do you know who I am?"
- Also they'll be releasing
Kingdom Hearts on the Switch
which is probably one of the
biggest reasons why it's...
- I mean like I was more
surprised about Minecraft Steve.
- That did break Twitter,
literally, it broke Twitter.
- That broke Twitter as well.
- Because like Sora I was just...
As someone who's not
that invested in Smash
or Kingdom Hearts I was like, I see it.
'Cause it wasn't that
big of a surprise for me
where I was just like,
"What the fuck!
Where did this come from?"
It was just like,
yeah, I mean they had a cloud on there,
they had (indistinct)
- See this is why I want
a Master Chief, man.
It would have been so out of left field.
- Yeah, Master Chief would
have been out of left field.
- Bro, imagine it, the
fucking announcement comes,
you hit the fucking halo music, bro.
This is full for memes.
I do not actually want...
I do not care if he is in it or not,
but I just want the meme potential-
- That's what most people
were saying about Sans
until they added a skin.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I just want Master Chief.
- They added a doom guy though as a skin.
- No, fuck off.
- Yeah.
- One of those skins is dooms guy.
- As a skin though, come on, man.
Doom guy could have been anything.
- Yeah, doom guy could have been anyone.
- [Man] It's a final update as well.
- Yeah, the final update, so
there's no more characters.
- Well the next Smash in
future, whenever that happens
we better get the Master Chief.
- Well, I mean, Nickelodeon
did a fighting game,
so who knows.
- No, no, no, I want the
Master Chief in Smash.
- What is this Nickelodeon fighter game?
- It's shit.
- It's basically,
they took all the Nickelodeon characters
and turned it to Smash.
- But it's actually like,
a well-designed game
from what I've heard.
I don't know, I don't really care.
- I saw a video of some guy just saying
how broken Spongebob was and-
- I mean he's the flagship character.
- And I never thought I'd see the word
Spongebob needs to get nerfed
(all laughing)
written in text but like
I saw it and I was like,
wow, what a time to be alive.
- Oh, man.
- I don't know, like, I'm super happy.
Like, I personally, have
never really sat down
and played the Kingdom Hearts game.
I only know so much about it
because I live with a Kingdom Hearts fan,
but like, I'm happy for
the Kingdom Hearts fans.
- I just know that every time
you talk to a Kingdom Hearts fan
they try to explain the story,
I'm just like, I don't know.
- I mean, it's like the you know,
it's like as a fake fan it's just like,
I understand how it feels getting--
- They just love it.
(group chattering)
- I'm glad they have something.
I wish I had something that I got there-
- I probably know more
about the Kingdom Hearts law
just purely because of Aki.
'Cause I had to sit
down and watch her play
all of Kingdoms Hearts 3
and every turning point,
I was like, "May I ask a question?"
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
May I ask several questions?
- I love the memes of like Mickey Mouse
wearing like a black hood.
I don't understand what's going on.
- I don't understand the context there.
- That's king mickey.
- But like Mickey Mouse
is wearing a black hood
and I'm like all right,
I should just like-
- And he gets into the
darkness and he fights enemies.
- [Man] The void.
- I don't know, this is totally unrelated
but it's just reminding me of this,
the PaRappa the Rapper
memes with the daffy duck,
have you seen that one?
- I think so, yeah.
- I slammed my penis
in the car door memes,
have you seen that?
(all laughing)
- It's really weird
when you just say that.
(all laughing)
- I spoke to Emily and Didus
and we were all like,
have you guys seen
the daffy duck where he slams
his penis in the car door
with PaRappa the Rapper?
And we were like, "Yes,
we love that meme."
I was like, yes!
It's such a dumb meme.
I'll show you later.
- All right.
- It's very weird when you just say that.
- When I hear that out of
context, I'm just like-
- It's one of those memes
that passed very fast
but I found it so funny
and I realized I'm such a child
and that is so funny.
- You're like crying.
- I know, there's something in my eye.
It's just so funny.
(Garnt laughing)
- Just the memory of this meme,
is just breaking this man.
- I just had to talk about, I don't know.
It reminded me of the, I don't know.
- I just love though like,
I'm not too invested in Smash anymore
but every time they announce a
new character I'm like, okay.
I always like try and keep up to date
with what the community is saying.
- I imagine that's how
it feels to like the NBA
and have the draft
- Yeah, yeah.
It's just like all of the predictions
I see from Smash fans, it's
just fucking hilarious.
Because with this last-
- You can bet,
You can bet on the characters.
- With this last drop,
there was three main predictions.
It was like, Sora, obviously,
Master Chief, obviously.
Third one was fucking Goku.
- And Crash Bandicoot as
well, I saw it as well.
- Yeah, Crash Bandicoot, but like Goku,
there was like an
alarming amount of people
who were like, Goku confirmed for Smash
- I'd be hyped for Goku.
- And I'm like,
I'd be hype but I just
can't imagine a game
where Goku beats up Mario.
- And Sonic.
- And Sonic, it just sounds fucking weird.
- Are you kidding me, that sounds amazing.
- It sounds amazing?
- I'd get hyped over that.
- What's that game where you
bet on characters that fight?
- Salty bets.
- Is that what it is?
Yeah, Salty Bets, that's it.
It turns into Salty Bets.
- It just sounds like a Salty Bets
- Yeah yeah yeah.
(Garnt laughing)
Salty Bets was just like
decades ahead of its time.
Hanson and Mickey is fighting Alucard.
Okay, sure, I'm down.
- Who will win?
And then Hanson and Mickey
comes back from One HP
and destroys Alucard
and you're like that checks out,
that sounds good.
Oh, my Lord.
Well, that's been fun
- Yeah, it has been fun.
- It's nice being back.
- It's good.
I'm just happy that I get to
see you guys again every week.
It's been too long.
I missed you guys, what can I say.
- We gotta get back in the rhythm again.
It's been a while, it's been a while.
- We'll get there, we'll get there.
- But you know what else I'm
glad about, the patreons.
- Damn, that felt good.
- It's been so long since
I've heard that, oh, my God.
- It's been a while
guys, it's been a while.
- Look at these lovely people who-
- Wonderful patreons who've
stuck around for the many weeks.
- For the one week.
- Many weeks that we've been away.
- The one week between the last episode.
But hey if you'd like to support the show
then consider supporting us on patreon,
on patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also follow us on Twitter.
Send us your memes on the subreddit,
and if you hate our face,
listen to us on Spotify.
I haven't said that in six weeks.
- [Garnt] I know.
- [Joey] And I said it flawlessly.
- It's like ingrained in here, man.
- [Joey] It really is, it really is.
- It is genuinely good to be back.
I was like, this is my
first day out of quarantine
and most people, when
they've been stuck inside
for like two weeks,
they wouldn't be excited
to go back to work,
but I was like genuinely excited
to go back to the office, man.
I was like, "Hell yeah, I
get to see my boys again."
Get to go to the office,
hell yeah, I'm excited.
- All right, well I guess,
nothing else to say.
We'll see you guys next
week, continuing as normal.
- Yeah.
- Bye guys.
- [Joey] Bye.
- [Garnt] Bye.
(upbeat music)